um
welcome to the house
health and human services and elderly
affairs committee also known as the
nicest committee in the house
um we have an alumna with us and uh
mary freitas is
sitting in for representative mckay and
representative friedus
and i sat next to each other my first
year until they moved me because
representative canark and i kept poking
each other
so welcome back
also uh the other seat filler please
introduce yourself
uh representative josh query okay nice
to have you here
and um i don't think the fact that this
mallet appeared suddenly at the head
table is an indication we're having hard
shell crabs for lunch it just sort of
showed up so
if anyone wants it um i don't know who
it belongs to but this is mine
open the exact session on
bill 1022 we're not going to necessarily
be taking them in numerical order
um a few people have asked if we could
hold a bill that is special to them
until tomorrow and
i've
so far been happy to exceed to that so
we are actually going to start with the
top of the list 10 22 permitting
pharmacists to dispense the drug
ivermectin by means of a standing order
and the chair
recognizes
representative cushman because there is
an amendment
thank you mr chairman and i'm passing
the amendment around right now it's 20
22 0 9 6 4.
and i brought down many of the amendment
uh groups from the fourth floor and just
ask you not hand them out until the bill
is called or we're going to drown in
paper
more than we usually do
so this amendment that's coming around
it does address some of the concerns
that were raised in the work group
on this bipartisan work group although
we could not reach a consensus in the
work group
after several meetings
but it addresses the concerns that were
raised
it it indicates that they have to
specify a screening protocol for each
patient a requirement to document the
screening performed and the prescription
in the patient's medical record
including a plan for referring for an
evaluation and treatment if adverse
effect events occur
it also removed the line that
nothing on the information sheet shall
discourage the use of ivermectin for the
treatment of covet 19 because if
ivermectin is a versatile drug and it's
it's got many uses so if if a physician
in a pharmacy
um want to enter into a standing order
agreement like this
to make ivermectin available for
treating parasites such as scabies and
not not
specifically for covet 19 then they
they shouldn't have to
not discourage if they feel that that's
in their interest
how would the amendment differ from the
bill as originally filed
yeah so in it's mostly
um
in
lines nine and sorry not lines
and 12 just some slightly changed
wording just to make it clear what needs
to be
included
again the screening performed and a plan
for referring for evaluation and
treatment of adverse events and then
also in paragraph
[Music]
sorry looking for it
it also um
places the statements that the board of
medicine
shall not deny revoke or suspend or
otherwise take disciplinary action
against a physician based on a
physician's failure to follow a standing
order provided
that were provided
using the provisions of this section
puts that into the statutes governing
the board of medicine
and likewise with the
advanced practice registered nurses
and the pharmacy pharmacists that just
put the puts those into the appropriate
statutes as well instead of having it
only be um
listed in this pharmacy statute
so it's actually the three new sections
at the end
section two three and four
and it also includes that the
information sheet that they give out so
this is section 5 of the bill starts on
line 25 the pharmacist shall provide
each recipient
with an information sheet written in
plain language which shall include but
is not limited to potential adverse
effects drug interactions food and drug
administration approved indications for
ivermectin use the importance of
follow-up care and healthcare referral
information
so really the main the important piece
of that i mean it's all important but
something of note is the indications for
ivermectin use so they are informed that
it's an off-label use
any questions for the representative
representative merchant
thank you mr chairman also thank you
represent cushman for taking the
question or just responding to it
i want to commend you for trying to make
some changes to it unfortunately i don't
think it fits what we're trying to get
to at least from a pharmacist's point of
view
a standing order is different than a
collaborative agreement the way this is
written an agreement is between a
provider and a pharmacist which spells
out exactly what it is which is what a
collaborative agreement's all about
standing order on the other hand is
really
authorization for the pharmacists to
follow protocol
and that's broadly used so without
having the underlying
protocol that we all can agree to and
vetted correctly
i don't know how we can use a standing
order as a pharmacist
so therefore
we're trying to take a collaborative
agreement approach and apply it to a
standing order approach and the two of
them don't fundamentally work that way
so that's why when i look at this bill
overall even though the drug may be safe
it still needs to have some sort of
guidelines for the pharmacist to follow
that have been vetted and built on
consensus so we did the same thing with
nicotine with hormonal contraceptive
therapy the process who went through to
develop the protocol plus the
forms used to give to the patient were
fully vetted between all three
disciplines
and it took time but it was at the end
of the day the appropriate thing to do
so without having that process in place
to get to us
through consensus
protocol
and agreement upon what the standard
form is going to say i could not support
this
question of the chair for the
representative if there was were a um
a tweak to the amendment
that deals with the uh terminological
problem would that be sufficient for you
no it would not mr chairman the reason
for it being is the key to it is the
protocol
until we have an agreement amongst the
professions amongst the disciplines of
what that protocol is
i think we're putting pharmacists into
crosshairs with liability because if
something happens heaven forbid it does
and that protocol has not been vetted
appropriately
then i think we're opening up the
pharmacist to a lot of liability that
they may not understand
or may be pushed into taken if you
action which should not be in their best
interest i still go back to the issue
about the protocol
thank you and since this is an exact
session it is not necessary to
ask a question not that we usually do
anyway but um
we definitely don't have to hear anyone
with any anything you wish to share or
ask of the amendment sponsor
representative knurk actually mine is a
question um
just a little confused on page one of
the amendment i'm sorry of the uh
here we are lines 29 to 31 let's say
talks about the board of medicine shall
not blah blah blah that's on page one
29-31
and then we have the new section over on
page two
that is lines seven through nine i'm
trying to understand why does that need
to be in both places could you just
clarify that for me sure so the statute
that we're looking at is in the pharmacy
statutes
so
um and it's not specifically under
um
it's not it's not specifically under
like the licensing so we just needed to
put it in the nursing and the physician
licensing statute so there's no
question
representative merchant thank you the
other thing which i'll bring to people's
attention here about the issue of a
standing order
when we have used standing orders in the
past what's included in there is a
requirement for continuing education to
be sure the pharmacist is educated
appropriately to follow the protocol
that's not in here
and i think goes back to my initial
concern is that we have a protocol
that's really not been vetted correctly
and we also have not identified how the
pharmacist should be trained to use the
protocol so those two things taken
together i think makes this bill
not passable
representative folsom
i'm not really sure who would have the
answer to this but can't the protocols
and the process of education be hammered
out in the rules process
representative merchant
it could be unfortunately there's no
requirement for it to be done
so
and right so you can't do that unless
the statute requires it and at that
point in time the statute does not
require it um if we went through rule
making process and had the boards like
we did with the other standing orders
vet things appropriately we could do
that but right now that's not a
requirement in this amendment nor in the
bill
representative weber
thank you um
i'm going to take a step backwards and
rather than wordsmithing just say that
we've already passed a bill
that clarifies that off-label use
is appropriate when a
provider
and a patient have had an appropriate
conversation about the medicine and its
use
we strengthened the protections for
people using off-label use and clarified
that they were very appropriate so i
think that's the way to go and i'm
absolutely opposed to this approach as a
matter of policy thank you
representative cushman thank you mr
chairman so i have several points
so
i understand what you're saying about a
collaborative agreement representative
merchant but that requires a prior
relationship with the patient in all
scenarios this drug is available in
many countries over the counter with no
protocols required it is incredibly safe
the patient could dose themselves how
they see fit so this would ensure that
there's an agreement between a physician
who's familiar with protocols that are
effective for what they want to treat to
issue that order and then give the
prescribing authority to the pharmacist
through dispensa through his ability to
his or her ability to dispense it
um
you know this is something that is
is needed quickly that's why i didn't
leave it up to rules uh well it was
needed quickly and we don't know what
the fall is going to bring
unfortunately the numbers have decreased
significantly but the problem with
establishing relationship with these
doctors ahead of time and we've had this
discussion is that they're hard to find
um
as far as liability
that's up to the pharmacist this doesn't
require any pharmacy or pharmacists to
enter into this kind of agreement it
just permits if there is a
a small pharmacy somewhere in the state
who wants to enter into this agreement
with a physician who's familiar with the
protocol and can write it and issue it
and they enter into this together then
whoever goes to that pharmacy can ask
for the ivermectin and be given it
representative leon thank you mr
chairman
i think what this ultimately comes down
to is harm reduction right now people
are getting ivermectin from india from
mexico on spring break in the dominican
republic
and also getting it from the the pet
store the farm stores
people are seeking it out and i would
prefer that people have available
ivermectin that's been manufactured in
fda compliant fda inspected facilities
i understand this doesn't meet all the
same same requirements that hormonal
contraception which is very dangerous
important but dangerous and tobacco
cessation and nicotine therapy that also
has significantly higher risks i
understand it doesn't hit all those
other metrics but people are using it
using one that is adulterated with
another substance because they're only
looking for ivermectin and not the other
things that are in the horse medicines
is dangerous and by doing this and
allowing those select pharmacies and
providers who do want to enter into this
the opportunity to do so so that fda
manufactured ivermectin is available i
believe is a benefit to our people and
that's why i'm supporting it
representative woods
thank you
i'm i'm troubled
we as representative weber pointed out
we already have
one bill that i think places it in the
proper position of having the physician
and the patient understand that this is
an off-label use and i think that's the
appropriate place
i don't think the legislature should be
practicing medicine
which is really basically what this is
we've done that before
you may recall that there was a
loud hue and cry
to have bone marrow transplants for
breast cancer
huge human cry and this legislature went
through the process of mandating
that insurance companies covered
well guess what
within six months it was found it would
be not only inappropriate but perhaps
dangerous
we don't want to go down that path
another example lay a trill hue and cry
about all the kids were being wasted
because this government would not allow
leia trail we're having to go to mexico
well guess what
turns out it was not as effective and it
was also dangerous
there is a human cry with covid
i will not
take
the vaccine
it's not fda approved no that's just
emergency that is not fully fda approved
yeah here we're
trying to legislate something that
circumvents that very process
i think that's the wrong approach
giving
a
standing order gives it the imprimatur
that this is really fully fully approved
by the fda
if you look on clinical trials
there are some that say it should be
looked at
the recent articles in the and the
journal medical
american medical association
new england journal of medicine say we
need some state looks like it could be
okay but the originals the studies we've
done
in those
that have just been recently reported
say it doesn't indicate that this is
really
the best medicine
so we have to be a little bit careful
what we're doing of practicing medicine
in this way
and for those reasons
i will have to vote against it
the chair asks representative cushman to
follow up on representative woods with
that off label bill that we've passed
does that make your bill not needed in
your opinion
in my opinion no it doesn't
we still have patients who don't know
where to find the doctors who will write
the prescription for ivermectin um and
if they know that there's a pharmacy
that they can just go to
it makes it much easier for them than to
go to a you know
it's more convenient than having to
go and find this doctor and set up an
appointment
but it's safer than going to the farm
store
anyone else representative merchant
if i know
that most pharmacies today
because of the politics behind us
will not stock the drug
therefore even if we have a standing
order we pass this
the
opportunity for a patient to go to a
local pharmacy to obtain the medication
which is the intent behind this becomes
null and void
so in essence i go back to what
representative weber said and also
represented wood i think the way to
approach this because both bills are
going to come through the state house
into the senate at about the same time
is to use the off-label use
at this point in time for people to be
aware of it a pharmacist in the state of
new hampshire can dispense a medication
from any licensed provider licensed by a
state in any state in this country
they can do it through telehealth
there's ways for them today
to have access to ivermectin and use the
system we have in place and not have it
slowed down
but getting this bill through in a
standing order does not mean that the
pharmacies and the pharmacists are going
to dispense it because
most of them probably are not going to
stock it
representative canarch
thank you and i wanted to just reflect a
bit on what representative woods said he
gave a nice historical
viewpoint of things and i think that's
helpful but
keeping it into the more recent time i
know that there were many comments made
in this committee at various points
about that there's this huge number of
studies on ivermectin that shows it's
effective
in my testimony when i testified about
this i went over the issues of how we
quali
judge the quality of the study
so we know whether or not a study is
actually valid
and that is not an issue of censoring or
not liking a point of view it is simply
the way we've done it now for the last
few decades in terms of looking to see
study design i don't know if any of you
took time to look at the couple of
studies sent out by the new hampshire
medical society it was under james
potter's name about three or four days
ago
but that's an example of the big
difference the sponsor distributed at
the time of the hearing
a paper
on 233 000 subjects sounds wonderful
it's a lot of people
but the way that people entered the
study is they were invited to come in if
they wish to do so and take the drug um
so
they if they walked in and they said hey
i'd like to do this then they were given
the drug
no randomization if you look at the two
articles that were sent
by potter
that's a standard
real proper study where you went to a
database from one of them to draw people
who were under treatment the other is
everybody admitted to the hospital they
were invited to join the study but then
they were randomized using computer
randomization it's not even just a
person assigning them it's all computer
number generated to make sure that it's
a true randomized and prospective study
the distribution the study distributed
at the time of the hearing is not
and if we look at these studies because
i've reviewed dozens of them most of
them are just very poor quality
again as i
stressed getting away from the politics
of this country
the cochrane collaboration which is
international consortium that i've
relied on for
good quality studies for decades
have also looked at it and again they
don't find negative but they simply
don't find any supporting evidence from
studies that are quality studies and
that's where they still are ongoing so i
agree that we should be not giving them
premature that this is actually
an accepted treatment because it isn't
and that's probably why people have a
hard time finding doctors who will
prescribe it is because the majority of
doctors follow
the actual
data with the best data we have
and that's an important thing that we
continue to do if somebody wishes to
prescribe it off label again we have
that authority over the under under the
other bill that we already passed
and i think that should be sufficient
and also online i understand people can
go to flccc online and go ahead and get
get information
and get a prescription as well so thank
you representative and would remind us
we have 23 bills and we are still
debating the amendment on the first one
i would not wish to think we're being
dilatory i if you have an original
thought that has not been stated i would
encourage you to put your hand up if
you're going to rehash what has been
said on both sides we have 23 bills
does anyone wish to speak further
thank you
the chair calls on representative
cushman to make a motion
thank you mr chairman i move to pass
amendment
2022-0964
h2 house bill 1022
and the second
okay representative um folsom
i have to ask if there's any further
discussion
in which case the chair calls on
representative cushman for further
motion
we do don't we
that wasn't being dilatory that was just
being stupid
would the clerk please call the roll on
amendments
four 2022-0964-h two house bill 1022
representative leon yes
representative mcmahon
mcmahon sorry
representative acton yes representative
gay
representative cushman yes
representative folsom yes representative
kelsey yes representative king yes
representative fault
yes representative delemus
representative weber
representative freitas no representative
snow absent representative knurk
yes i'm sorry no no no no
i i got you
representative
representative cleary
no
representative cannon no
representative nutter upham no
representative shapiro no representative
woods no representative merchant
no
representative pearson yes
eleven nine the amendment carries eleven
to nine
the chair now hopefully
calls on representative cushman for
further motion thank you mr chairman i
motion
the bill as amended by
amendment 0964-h be voted ought to pass
and is it second that representative
delemus seconds it
i must ask if there's any further
discussion
seeing none the clerk
please call the role on house bill 1022
is amended by
amendment 2022-0964
representative leon yes representative
mcmahon representative acton
representative gay
representative cushman yes
representative folsom yes representative
kelsey yes representative king yes
representative cofoult yes
representative delemus
representative weber
representative freitas
representative snow absent
representative knurk no
representative query
no representative cannon no
representative nutter upham no
representation shapiro no representative
woods no representative merchant no
representative pearson yes 11 9. and
representative cushman if you have not
already written the committee report
please do so and
i will
do we recognize representative merchant
for that
representative merchant appears to have
volunteered
and we thank him
and the qualified one to do so as a
pharmacist
we've got to get this stuff in by noon
on wednesday
we have to
so
please i want those blurbs asap
this ends the um exec session on house
bill 2022
let me get all this stuff together
uh 10 22. would you believe i just said
that to see if people were paying
attention you're right
now i am going to open the hearing on
house bill
1077.
you have been sent
a copy of the amendment
by email but here is hard copy now
coming around to you and i'll
let you have a chance
to
look at it
again
we're doing 10.77
uh
and for the record under house bill 1022
412 people signed in in support and 327
signed in in opposition and i'd remind
people in the opinion of many these
numbers are at least a bit squiffy it
has to do and i say that about bills
where
way more people signed in for me than
against me because it just means
somebody managed to get out the emailers
and if there's an amendment
remember these sign in and sign in
against
are for the original bill not the
amended bill so anyway
the chair recognizes himself to speak to
his amendment
our house committees
are sometimes presented with a bill
asking for something to be put into law
in response we often hear someone say
the bill is unnecessary
because the subject is
already covered
in the law
and we can debate whether that's true or
not adequately speaking
but much of the time i find myself in
sympathy with those who
just want to make sure
whether the facts
of whether it's covered in the law are
there or not
i recognize that there's
concern and maybe even fear
and for me that's also a real thing
when conversion therapy was previously
debated no one could cite an example of
a licensed professional in medicine or
counseling using shock treatment or
locking somebody in a closet or
subjecting someone to pornography
but irrespective of that the fact
remains that some tender aged people
might be counseled
dare we say pressured or forced
to become something that is against
their will
even if it's the will of their parents
i understand the proper function of
professional counseling is to be client
directed
so i honor the concern raised
as i honor
the fear expressed
however i also know of tender age
persons who are experiencing same-sex
attractions they do not wish to have
and want professional help to work
through
those feelings
i've spoken with professionals who have
told me they're afraid
of having sanctions brought against them
for offering services to this group of
clients
some have told me that their fear
is unrealistic because the law doesn't
read that way
again that's debatable
and whether this is true or not i
recognize the fear that is present
here
for me that fear is a real thing as well
so i wish to honor
the fear
the concern
i wish to honor what i believe is the
appropriate use of counseling that it is
client centered
and that counseling is
not forced
on the client
by professionals
in addition this amendment says that
across the board professional services
should be client determined
and as i was working on this amendment i
wondered why the people who were
mentioned were just those under 18.
how about 19 year olds should they not
be
free
from having counseling
forced on them
or 20 year olds
should not adult clients also
be able to have counseling the intent of
which comes from
what this person wants
shouldn't this be true straight across
the board
no forced
counseling
and
protections
so that is my amendment
and
as chair i will
welcome any
discussion for questions representative
merchant
i want to commend you for taking the
stab at doing this
however i do concern myself against
anyone's
will particularly a minor
i know growing up as a child
my parents were
gospel they were
you never questioned my
family my
support system and so forth it wasn't
because they were hard on me just
because their acceptance of me was so
critical
that whatever they were recommending
that i should be doing is what i did
so even though it says against the will
i concerned about how
independent that will really is when a
parent is basically at that point in
time
saying to do something
even though they don't believe it or
don't think they should do it
the reality is
they're god
so therefore i don't think you can
actually put something that says against
the will because i don't think they have
independent will
at what age to what age
i'm 68 now and i still to my father
who's 90 and his
opinion of me and what he has still
carries tremendous amount of weight so i
don't think we ever believe that
representative pearson i think
we look to our parents with a whole
different viewpoint regardless of her
age more so when we're young for sure
but even to this day i look to my father
and his opinion means a lot to me
thank you representative shapiro
yes thank you mr chairman and and i
would agree i i appreciate your efforts
to change this to
um
solve the problem that you see even
though you
are clearly against any kind of coercive
therapy so i
give you kudos for making this attempt i
would also not support this amendment
for a variety of reasons
i was able to speak to
dr good now who is
chair of the board of mental health who
informs me that there has never been a
complaint since the statute came into
being of someone
inappropriately talking to a client
about
their
questioning their sexual orientation or
identity
it's just
has never been brought to the board
so i would say that
this is a problem this is an attempt to
fix a problem that really does not exist
um
i know
we disagree about that um but
my long experience in the mental health
field tells me that
um the problem of
clinicians being fearful about talking
to young people about their sexuality
about their discomfort
about their um
feelings that are not aligned with what
they think they should
be feeling
it's just i don't believe that it's a
problem
therefore i think there's no reason for
this bill or for the
amendment
i also would like to just speak a little
bit to what representative merchant um
said
which is that i think there is just a
power differential between
adults
and 15 16 17 year olds
and
sometimes we wish they would listen to
us more
but in fact they listen to us a lot
and i think that
[Music]
this bill the way it's written the
amendment the way it's written would
still allow a parent to choose who the
therapist was
who the who the what kind of therapy the
therapist practiced what their biases
might be and send their child to that
therapist
and i think therefore the problem
i would also say that in the last
section where it talked about
if the therapy in question is alleged to
have consisted of speech only the
relevant licensing authority shall
presume that the therapy was client
directed
and i know you put in a less clause
but i would say that just in general
speech only therapy or talk therapy
certainly
can be
coercive can be pressured and um
i don't think this is the kind of like
question we want to be litigated um in
each case in front of a licensing board
um i think the licensee boards go by
professional ethics
um and
they will take care of these kind of
situations without this bill
so for all those reasons i would vote
against the amendment as well as against
the bill
in response representative
if somebody now of any age
but especially tender age
is dropped off
at a therapist
with the words
fix him
and that is the charge to the therapist
i want
the fear of that client yelping loudly
to be honored
just as i want
those therapists who have told me
they're running scared
in the other direction i want to honor
the fear
even if it's not necessary in law
i want to honor both sides
representative snow
thank you i do apologize
you are the keeper mary of the
microphone and the on off switch it's a
coveted position
which is why we brought you in today
having only read the i i did get to see
your amendment ahead of time so i did i
did know i put it up right now
so i do know a little more about i just
want to make one other point that he
didn't make and i do have a letter here
from the national association of social
workers that confirms that there has
never been a problem in that particular
area and that no social worker that
anyone knows of that if they had a
circumstance like that when someone was
dropped off i personally would not have
a problem seeing that youngster as long
as i didn't make a
promise to him that there's something i
could do
to convert his sexual identity
that's the only thing that's out but
certainly to deal with the feelings that
he's had
when you talked about the desperation
there's absolutely no prohibition to any
of us
from doing that and i would just like
also like to point out one other thing
knowing yourself and you do sometimes
see people like this
and i know you as a person and i know
you as an approach would be the most
gentle person in the world about how you
handle this
but also when you talk with some of
these professional organizations even
the most gentle approach
is totally ineffective in making the
change and secondly even the very gentle
approach does tend to foster feelings of
guilt
shame and social isolation even done in
that form and obviously when you get up
to the more coercive methods
you get into some very dangerous
situations even cruel and and perverse
and
i think
to ban this is absolutely necessary i
would like to see it banned not just for
licensed professionals but for anyone
any self-appointed life coach
sexual identity counselor that called
himself that that if they engage in this
that they ought to be banned too but i
don't know how to go about doing that
and that's not included in this bill
but i would have to oppose the amendment
only because i really feel that more
harm than help can be done even though i
know your intention
is to do the right thing i'm sorry mr
chair okay anyone else
representative leon
thank you mr chairman
i am a new member on the new hampshire
council to prevent suicides and i
actually sat in on one of the data
meetings and they were going through
some of the data that they had from the
youth risk behavior survey
it doesn't have trans as an identity on
there they had straight gay bisexual not
sure and there were people who didn't
answer
what was really terrifying looking at it
was that the not sure and the bisexual
had so much more of an increased risk of
suicidal ideation and suicide attempts
there was a large group of individuals
who aren't sure how to categorize
themselves i don't know if that's
because trans was left off of the survey
which may be the reason because if your
answer is not there you're going to say
not sure that's a good test taker
but i
the reason why i was working to try and
find a way where people can go in and
have a safe place where they can discuss
how they feel
and the practitioner doesn't feel that
they have to only have affirmative
counseling for the for the therapy that
they can explore it with somebody who
might not be sure they might not be
ready to make that move
or maybe they don't want to
but to
remove that language that says only
affirmative therapy because
i i don't know how it's going to impact
each individual i do know that
counseling against somebody's will
directive therapy is immoral and
unethical the question
i just want to make sure that we have
those protected places because these
kids are attempting suicide at a much
higher rate
and i don't want to take any opportunity
for them to get counseling to express
their feelings and determine who they
are
not be told who they are but to
determine who they are themselves
and hearing from counselors who are
afraid to see minors because of this law
means that our shortage of mental health
professionals is even worse
and i i believe ethics will keep any of
these course of things out and that's
why i want to make sure we increase
access
representative cushman
thank you mr chairman i would just like
to follow up on what representative leon
was saying
not only ethics but i think also
liability is a huge motivator to stay
away from
coercive therapy and it's pretty clear
in this that
any therapy that is coercive in nature
that is not in the
interest of
what direction the patient would like
the therapy to go is entering into
dangerous territory for a therapist and
that's a great deterrent
and
it's not about what the parents want
you know most therapy sessions are a
half hour to an hour long with the
patient privately
and if there is a teenager in there who
wants to explore their sexual
orientation or gender identity
um
this this ensures that they can do that
and that more therapists will be willing
to have the conversations
and
you know they won't be concerned that
they're going to face disciplinary
action just for having those
conversations so we need this bill
representative woods
thank you
just in terms of the word um affirmative
i
didn't think of it in the terms of being
affirmative for a particular
end point i to interpret affirmative
being supportive
of the individual regardless of what
their discussion may be i want this i
want that or i'm not sure
supportive i and i interpret the word
affirmative in that vein
so would i sir representative shapiro
yes thank you mr chairman um
i would just want to acknowledge that
it was a failure on the part of people
who
wanted to defeat this bill to not have
clinicians come
and
testify on the other side i think there
were two psychologists and a
psychiatrist
who testified that this was
you know that they were intimidated by
this law and would therefore not talk to
adolescents about their sexuality um i
acknowledged that they were here i
acknowledge that people were not here on
the other side
um i don't know how to convince you of
this but
my
my absolute belief is that they are
outliers
and that um if people had known and
people had organized around this
conversion therapy ban being in um
in danger that you would have had many
many more clinicians and maybe that has
to wait till it gets to the senate if it
somehow makes it through the house but
um
once again i would just say that i think
this is a an attempt to fix a problem
that absolutely does not exist
i spoke with
two counselors who are not in the room
who agreed with those who were in the
room so that only makes it five to no
shows
but still
it wasn't just the three representative
cannon
thank you mr chair um
excuse me
when this when the original bill was
first brought forward the language that
was submitted for our statute is was
identically used in a number of other
states and still is in place
and
a challenge that we were faced with is
recognizing that there were a number of
youth who were already
had already
had difficulty with conversion therapy
and many had taken their life because of
it
even myself
not having a supportive home back in the
60s that i could even think about coming
out as well as a church then
thought i was an abomination
forced me into the closet with a lot of
pain
when we brought this the original bill
forward we didn't include
people over the age of 18
because they have the right to decide
for themselves already
as
as adults
and so we did not include that in like
because they have the right to do
whatever they want to do
where a child is under the
protection of their parents or their
legal guardians
i i really appreciate your efforts to
improve this bill
but i'm afraid that i'm i'm not going to
be able to support it
thank you amendment
who hasn't spoken yet before we go to
round two
representative snow
i would just like to point out in
response to what uh representative leon
said
it is true that people that are going
through this struggle are at a much
higher risk of suicide
but i've also read articles to show that
people who are going through this
struggle and engage in this kind of
treatment are even higher
the rate it tends to promote that
thinking even further rather than reduce
it and
that's the scary part for me
representative
query
thank you
um i just want to follow up on what uh
representative snow just said um
this
this is a hard debate um
i grew up in rural midwest
and this is something that
um
that i grew up with
a lot of friends being put through this
whether it was through personal
counseling of you know licensed
therapist or
church
sanctioned
groups that would
try to help this and
to just further on
the fact that
kids follow what their parents
say
they want to make their parents proud
and when they go into these conversion
therapies
and they are continuing to have the same
feelings
the same same-sex feelings that they are
there to get rid of
they are only seeing themselves as more
failures to their parents
they are only making themselves realize
that there's no way out for them
which is leading them closer and closer
to making that decision
this is an ongoing
crisis
for the lgbtq community
as we see bills like this
rolling back
protections
for us to live our lives
it brings even the most secure and out
people
to the edge of making those decisions we
are speaking to the amendment
representative
in that case i will cut it
there but i will just say
uh i am against this amendment and the
underlying bill
representative king
all right i'm i'm um
sitting here a little confused and
if you know me well that's not a
that's not a
um
unusual so
um i know when this bill originally came
it just just flat out said repeal
the original
the law that's currently in place
and
i don't think there was a single member
on this committee that agreed with
conversion therapy just to be
square on this
and so what
the chairman has done
is gone back and tried to define
what conversion therapy is because we
had people here at the hearing
that said they were confused as well
and that they needed boundaries on where
they could be
in their therapy
and i think that what this amendment's
trying to do is to outline those
boundaries am i mistaken
that was my intent
representative kanark
just a quick thing i think the original
the statute as it stands does
do those boundaries and for example it
says conversion therapy shall not
include so on and so on identity
exploration so it is not something where
one has to use affirming and
representing leon's thing but more in
representative woods it does give those
boundaries we're taking away those
boundaries with this amendment
representative merchant
thank you mr chairman
has this amendment we've talked about
the
five therapists that came and spoke
about three and two i found like three
and two and yeah three and two which
that's i think goes back to five
um in regards to
this issue because
without them looking at this amendment
and understanding it
from their viewpoint is this going to
fix their
objections to the bill to begin with all
five
have read this amendment while it was
being crafted one made a suggestion all
five have read it as you see it and they
believe yes it will
deal with their fears thank you in a way
that the original law on the books does
not
thank you
seeing nothing further the chair
recognizes himself to a move amendment
zero nine two one
and looks for a second representative
lay on
and
having discussed it and seeing no more
hands
would the clerk please call the roll on
amendment 0921 to house bill 1077.
yes representative mcmahon
representative acton yes representative
gay
representative cushman
yes representative folsom yes
representative kelsey
representative king yes representative
cofolt
yes representative delemus
representative weber
representative freitas no representative
snow no representative knurk no
representative query
representative cannon
representative nutter upham no
representative shapiro no representative
woods no representative merchant no
representative pearson yes
11 10. 11 10 the amendment passes the
chair recognizes himself for a motion
and the motion is ought to pass as amen
amended by
zero nine two one and looking for second
representative cofault now further
discussion representative corey if you
wish to continue you may
from when you cut off
you you can wave off if you wish
yeah um
as i was saying i think
the the purpose of this bill
um i can
hear
and understand i wasn't here in the room
i was watching online when this bill was
originally heard
um
is
is all about
the the therapists and not the people
who are being put in that therapy
um
i i respect looking and getting the
having the the therapists and counselors
and all of them
give uh feedback on the amendment and
therefore the bill
um however i would love to know how many
uh people in the lgbtq plus community
you look to and asked for their
feedback on this
the question of the chair um
i have not
asked anyone because the numbers of
emails i've got
from those individuals you just
delineated was considerable i didn't
need to ask for any more i had several
write me individually
representative weber
thank you mr chairman and i just wanted
to state that um
i certainly appreciate the amendment
i appreciate the concern behind the
amendment i really appreciate the
removal of the
18 year old
line although i agree with
representative cannon that people who
are over the age of 18 may make their
own decisions and therefore they can
they are under a less
coercive situation than they would be if
they were a minor
i just think that the drafting of the
language on page two
uh
is really opening a whole set of other
cans of worms and uh
i
don't see the reason to change
that having been said i think we're
better off with the original statute and
that is certainly
the advice that i have gotten from the
many people of the affected communities
who have written to me and said they
want to keep the original statute and
that was as an affirmative statement so
that's how i will be voting thank you
the reason for
the paragraphs three and four
was because of lines one and two on page
two unprofessional conduct and shall be
subject to such discipline as the
relevant licensing authority deems
appropriate
well if you're gonna sue me
you're gonna take my license away
we've gotta have some definitions here
and three and four is
akin
to
[Music]
items that i have seen in other
laws that follow
the statements of lines one and two
anyone else
representative cannon
thank you mr chair
this may shock a few few folks but um
as i've read through your amendment
as as it applies to the bill
that's in front of us
where it does not
force a repeal of the existing
statute
it
does
improve the statute for a number of
folks
and as such
i will be supporting
a bill
in this with this amendment
thank you thank you
sing nothing further
representative snow
representative freitas to the rescue
thank you thank you very much i don't
know why i have much problems with
microphones
i i know this may sound a lot like sour
grape what we're doing is enabling a
bill to come into effect that's
surprising to make it more possible for
people to get a treatment technique that
clearly does not work about the
preponderance of evidence
if the words are against the
individual's will and the individual
doesn't want treatment the individual
knows doesn't work i think we've got
an out
seeing nothing further
the motion before us is house bill 1077
as amended by 0921
h
the
number of people who signed up in
support of the original bill
was
and against
for the original bill but we're not
voting on that we're voting on as
amended zero nine two one as
moved by
the chair and is seconded by
representative cofoult with the
committee would the clerk please call
the role representative leon yes
representative mcmahon
representative acton yes representative
gay
representative cushman yes
representative folsom yes representative
kelsey
representative king yes representative
cofoult yes representative delemus
representative weber
no
representative freitas
representative snow no representative
knurk no
representative query
no
representative cannon
yes
representative nutter upham no
representative shapiro no representative
woods
no
representative merchant yes
representative pearson yes
the bill passes as amended 13-8 and the
chair
taking a privilege
yes it is 13 21. i purposely was really
careful this time
it it was all the republicans plus two
democrats which is 13.
the chair wishes to continue
if we find this doesn't work
as intended
or even
if this could be improved
please make me your first phone call
thank you
this ends the hearing on house bill 10
17.
seven
i've uh
i'll take care of the blurb and who
wishes who will be riding the minority
i'm sorry
we'll discuss it and let you know you'll
discuss it and let me know can you let
me know before we leave today because i
have to join the foreman thank you
thank you
all right
representative shapiro has volunteered
okay
thank you
now
open the hearing on house bill uh the
executive session on house bill 10
and
um
um the copy hard copies of the amendment
are going around
10 45.
and while i think of it the original
bill not amended
520 people signed in for it 123 signed
in against it
and yet
a funny thing happened on the way to the
amendment
the prime sponsor of the bill sitting at
that very table
uttered
a phrase
i have now given up for lent
this is only housekeeping
at which point
the bill's prime sponsors dear friends
proceeded to rip the housekeeping
amendment
into small pieces
which was a wonderful thing thank you
because it made the prime sponsor go
back and look at things afresh and anew
and place a call to commissioner
shibanet
saying
while i'm up
how can i help
and the commissioner said
well
the
if i can do a nova scotia accent
probably not
the
ethics
advisory committee as constituted in law
has wonderful people in it but most of
them aren't trained in ethics
i have groups of people who speak to me
economically politically
people representing various special
interest groups but i need an ethics
committee comprised of people trained in
ethics
at which point i got to meet some
fascinating people in the realms of
law
and medicine in psychology
and all of that
who said what a wonderful idea let's
have the ethics advisory committee be
made up of various people who have
studied to some good degree or other the
field of ethics
now ethics isn't
this exactly the same
from profession to profession but
there's a lot of overlap the venn
diagram shows a lot of commonality in
how to think on an issue ethically
so the members of the committee as
delineated in the amendment
were run by
the commissioner
who will benefit from this committee and
she has given her
imprimatur to this list
so
the original prime sponsor is very
grateful for the
funny journey that led us to this point
and wishes to
move the amendment
to
h
and is looking for a second
is that a second representative woods
yes thank you sir
now let's discuss
so once again guys thanks for uh
shooting down the original
sometimes we do allow an engine rebuild
seeing hearing nothing the motion before
us is actually the amendment
902 to house bill 1045 is moved by the
chair and seconded by representative
woods will the clerk please call the
role representative
yes
representative mcmahon
representative acton yes representative
gay
representative cushman yes
representative folsom yes representative
kelsey yes representative king yes
representative kobalt yes representative
delemus
representative weber
representative freitas
representative snow
representative knurk yes representative
query yes representative cannon yes
representative nutter upham yes
representative shapiro yes
representative woods yes representative
merchant yes representative pearson yes
21-0
chair recognizes himself for a further
motion in the motion is
ought to pass on house bill 1045 as
amended by 2022-0902
h the chair moves and someone
representative woods once again seconds
any further discussion
then the clerk please may call the roll
representative leon yes representative
mcmahon
representative acton yes representative
gay
representative cushman
representative folsom yes representative
kelsey representative king yes
representative cofoult yes
representative delemus representative
weber
representative freitas yes
representative snow yes representative
knurk yes representative querrey
yes representative cannon yes
representative nutter upham yes
representative shapiro
yes
representative woods yes representative
merchant yes representative pearson yes
21-0
consent
consent wow
um
i already wrote the blurb
since the hearing on house bill 1045
the
exec session on
10 45.
now open the exact session on house bill
1439 relative to hospital visitation
policies prime sponsor was
representative rice
and we have actually
two amendments
and if they have not been passed out yet
they may be at this time representative
weber's amendment 946
representative leon cushman rice and
kelsey 953
and
okay the weber one is coming around
and where's yours
oh
okay
uh 10
39 is not in anyone's possession
at the moment
uh
do i have a staff member here i do not
yes
you just said 10 39 do you mean 14 39 39
14 39 excuse me okay
yes and it's being passed around
and you said i do have a staff member
here
what about the leon amendment because we
do not have that um we're checking into
why that hasn't showed up yet oh okay
yes
do i have a staff member in this room
it can be such a headache
she's making copies now in the next room
and by the way we don't meet here
tomorrow
i don't remember where we are but it was
in the notice that was handed out
wait a minute
i do
no i don't i thought i did do i
we will be meeting tomorrow in rooms 201
3.
apparently finance wants its run back
tomorrow we sent them so much stuff
so please read over the weber amendment
because the leon amendment will be
forthcoming
thank you
sexy
i think
here's your original thank you
okay we've got an amendment coming from
representative leon
yep
and for the record
signing in on behalf of in favor of this
original bill
109 people
signing in against the original bill
4.
how about
looks like everybody
foreign
oh
give you about a minute more and then
we're going to ask both representative
webber and representative leon to
explain their amendments
i only made 22
uh well i
my amendment is
2022.0946h
and what i did was i took
a significant amount but not all of the
original bill and i placed it into the
patient's bill of rights
um
as
number
as as
an addition to the end of the patient's
bill of rights
in doing so i kept all four of the
pieces in the original bill
that
the visitation policies might be limited
or restricted when the presence of
visitors would be medically or
therapeutically contraindicated in the
best clinical judgment of health care
professionals that is not in
um
the leon amendment but i think maybe i
should just talk to mine and and then
talk
we'll discuss among ourselves afterwards
um
the other um
issue that we the other things that we
changed was that the health care
facility is going to do its own
drafting and posting of policies rather
than requiring that from the department
and i
just changed
the wording on lines five to nine
because
when inserting it in the patient's bill
of rights i i changed it to sort of
track as far as i could the existing
language and the patient's bill of
rights about the patient shall have the
right to so
that's slightly redrafted and i put
uh minors and adults in the same
paragraph so that's those are the
changes that i made but
i i want to point out that in keeping
the original language i i kept the
language which has i believe been
approved in other places so thank you
thank you
representative leon on your amendment
which is
thank you mr chairman and thank you
representative weber for doing most of
the lifting for me um as you pointed out
um our amendment removes the line that
says um
oops
i'm reading it from yours here the
presence of visitors will be medically
or therapeutically contraindicated in
the best clinical judgment of healthcare
professionals because there was a lot of
concern that that would just allow just
a straight out veto from some of the
doctors in one of these scenarios
in order to recognize that in some
scenarios and some time frames there may
be a need to further
limit visitors we added the word written
to what's line 20 on our amendment so
visitors are non-compliant with written
hospital policy
that would allow the hospitals to make
clear what they need to do in terms of
their visitation for reimbursement from
the federal government
because they have a certain protocol
because hospitalizations are over a
certain rate it would allow them to have
the flexibility so long as they make
that available to patients prospective
patients and their loved ones
this is trying to honor transparency and
say that the hospital so long as they
share their plans may make the decisions
that are best for the practice of
medicine in their hospital so we believe
that that allowed us to balance the
rights of the patients the needs of the
hospital and all of the different
stakeholders by just requiring those to
be written in that policy so that is the
main difference there
representative weber the other main
difference is that
my amendment moves the
policy to the patient's bill of rights
because these are talking about the
rights of the patient
whereas the leon amendment i believe
keeps
this as part of the licensing statute
rather than moving it to the patient's
bill of rights
yes it does thank you sorry i apologize
um and if you look on page 2 lines 18
through 20 we actually make that same
new number
roman 22
and we simply reference to that statute
and the licensing which would say which
says the patient shall be entitled to
have visitors pursuant to rsa 151 to j
um so that that's not all
gumming up the works within the patient
bill of rights
but i appreciate that putting it in the
bill of that is lines 18 through 20 on
page two of the amendment
um and but i appreciate that having that
information there i see both arguments
of leaving it in the facilities
licensing or in putting it fully in
patients in the patient bill of rights
we just wanted to make sure that the
hospitals knew that they needed to write
that policy and make it available and
that's why we we remained with it in the
original section and just linked it back
with that new paragraph in section three
page two lines eighteen through twenty
follow-up representative shapiro
thank you representative leon
this is just a clarification
are are you saying
that
the
line that's in representative weber's
amendment about
visitors could be restricted if
medically or therapeutically
contraindicated
is really included in your
letter c
as long as it was in the
in the written hospital policy that it
if that was the hospital policy if it's
in their written policy then yes
but we want to have them have a written
policy but could that policy be a
changing policy you know based on like
for example a surge of covet or does it
have to be a
um
well
it's a written policy one that's made
available to patients and prospective
patients
i think that
i can't imagine they'd be updating it
hour by hour even day by day
but
as situations change as they ebb and
flow they'll be able to be clear with
the community that they serve about how
they're approaching the current
situation thank you
representative weber
i just want to be clear that i
without the language about the presence
of visitors would be medically or
therapeutically contraindicated then i
think that a hospital that
denies visitation on that basis is very
much at risk and this is in their
licensing statute so they are at risk of
losing their license
so that's item number one
i would also point out uh with respect
to item number
uh the the issue of uh inclu
incorporating it by reference into the
patient's bill of rights
there are lots of places where the
patient's bill of rights is is you know
tacked to the wall or printed on a card
and handed to a patient
and handing them something that says
nothing in this section shall supersede
the right of a patient who is terminally
ill to have visitors pursuant to rsa 151
colon 21
xviii
i whip out my computer and i have a
direct link to the statutes so i would
look that up but i think most patients
wouldn't and i i think they would be
comforted by having words
but my real concern is the location
and the lack of the other the other
language and i
i want to thank everybody on the
subcommittee who worked very hard
because
we are all
concerned about patients having the
appropriate support
at
a really difficult time
but
we just were unable to agree on the way
to go about it so
representative leon wishes to respond um
thank you mr chairman and thank you
representative weber if you look at the
lines just below that that would be the
section going into the patient bill of
rights it would be line 20 which would
be roman 22 saying the patient shall be
entitled to have visitors pursuant to
rsa 151 2j
the one that you pointed out roman roman
9 is the one that makes sure that this
doesn't limit that end of life care and
i do want to thank you and everybody
else on the subcommittee too i think
it's quite impressive how close we are
on these two dueling amendments and i
view that as a success um in the process
and collaboration
representative
yes just a clarification i think
representative leon said that
the
if we look at the original bill lines 14
and 15 the presence of visitors would be
medically or therapeutically
contraindicated and so on
that that would be subsumed by point c
on line 20 in the amendment but which
amendment oh sorry her amendment uh
representative both her
uh you get a point there representative
leon's amendment
um
line 20 says visitors are non-compliant
with written hospital policy right yes
the point is that speaking of a visitor
not being compliant not that the they
would have a policy against a specific
visitation in a certain setting
you'd want to have it say visitation is
not compliant with hospital policy this
says a visitor so that would be a person
who says i'm not going to wear a mask
when it's required so i don't think that
the
segment section a on the original bill
is subsumed into
c on the amendment
because i think it's referring to a
person not to a policy when we say
visitor not visitation
that's just my own personal
interpretation
representative merchant
i am totally 100 confused
so what i'm looking through these two
amendments
they both seem to indicate
the patient's bill of rights but this
sounds like a smart about the visitors
rights
so are we talking about the visitors
right so we're talking about the
patients rights because i'm really
confused between the two which one we're
actually talking about
representative weber
okay well i'll take the first stab at it
and we'll call done first it
it came to us
as
more on the side of visitors rights and
a number of people commented that this
was really a patient right
rather than a visitor's right
so the language
may be
a little bit skewed towards visitors
rights but
the thing that we were trying to do
the lang but the language in both cases
says that
the minor is entitled to or the adult is
entitled to so it is a patient right
the differences are
and these i believe in representative
leon may correct me if i am wrong
in the weber amendment
we have retained specifically
that the presence of visitors would be
medically or therapeutically
contraindicated in the best clinical
judge of health care professionals
this is line 10 and 11 of the weber
amendment and it does not appear in the
leon amendment because that was one of
the things we were having difficulty
agreeing on
i don't believe that that can be added
to a hospital policy in the absence
of our authorization
or if it is added in the absence of our
authorization
the hospital policy as a whole could be
challenged because that isn't in there
the thing that all of us struggled with
in our discussions
was to balance the rights
of patient a
to have the appropriate support
and comfort of their loved ones or their
chosen
people and the right of patient b
to have is
least
unsafe an environment as we know how to
provide them
those are competing in many cases in a
time of pandemic and and under other
conditions as well
and i think that we all
wanted to get to a point where
you know obviously no people aren't
showing up in the emergency in the
operating room and demanding to be there
it it makes no sense but to have people
have appropriate support on the one hand
and appropriately safe care on the other
hand
the difference between the way we did it
aside from that one line
was that
my amendment puts it in the patient's
bill of rights which is where something
that is a patient's right ought to go
and which representative leons also does
only
incorporating it by reference which i
don't think is as useful as seeing the
actual words
but
representative leons has it in the
actual hospital licensing statute
rather than
as well as in by reference in the
patient's bill of rights
and that means that the hospitals are at
far greater risk
particularly without the protections of
the line that i insisted be in mine
when it comes to licensing as to whether
they have complied with the licensing
statute or not
chair asked paula minahan to come to the
table please
because she just might know what a few
things about hospitals
thank you
representative paula minnehan hospital
association
did so is there a particular question um
so regarding the patient bill of rights
um
it makes more sense to us that it be in
the patient bill of rights um and this
did come up during the work session that
we believe um it should be the focus
should be on the patient so um
i um i do agree with representative
weber um and i we actually are fine with
that with representative weber's
amendment moving it into the patient
bill of rights it is um always um
a challenge when you or you can
appreciate so that's why it just makes
much more sense to focus on the patient
the um what i believe is um i'm just
seeing the leon amendment now but um by
taking out the um
the sec the a thus the a in the original
bill relative to the therapeutic
medically and therapeutic um
indications that is a non-starter for us
it is that makes it a a really really
problematic bill and we have
testified to that and have stated that
our members are very concerned about any
removal of that
representative leon for a response um
thank you mr chairman uh my question
would be um or sorry i guess what i'm
trying to figure out is i'm looking at
this and saying that the visitors the
visitors would be the ones that would be
asked not to be in the room or not be in
the facility if it was medically or
therapeutically contraindicated
and if the visitors are the ones who are
having the behavior modified then it
would be a matter of the visitors being
compliant or non-compliant with the
written hospital policy
there's been so much confusion and so
much stress for patients and their loved
ones to understand what they actually
can do when they can be in a room and
when they can't be in the room
and people who are missing the end of
somebody's life because they declined
faster than it was expected that knowing
that it's not just about them and
whether or not the staff likes them
but knowing what the policy is
would be really comforting for a lot of
these families who are going through a
lot of trauma and i respect that the
hospitals and the medical professionals
are as well but um this is trying this
is trying to balance
these needs and so
um currently the hospital's policies are
on their website as as my testimony had
indicated and if you go on the
hospital's websites they are on there
this is about establishing the policies
and they are done with very
careful consideration by clinicians and
um and
depending on what the circumstances are
forget about covid um we may we may have
an ebola outbreak which we had at one
point we may have a flu outbreak
they need to and and i think there was a
comment made that they don't change
their policies every hour but i had one
hospital indicate they changed their
policies twice in one week that is a lot
they have to go through a very extensive
process for determining their policies
again with the clinicians and those that
are infectious disease specialists so
that is very concerning to us to remove
that language
and i am concerned that this will just
cause more confusion honestly um and um
we don't have a state law now um
the hospitals are trying to be as clear
as possible for the patient for the
visitors but
you're saying about getting into the
room they may not even be able to be
allowed in the hospital depending on the
situation fortunately things are much
better now but um during a
during the surge they were struggling
with patients
spilling out of their icus and and they
had no space
so it's it's very troubling to remove
that language i think it's going to
actually cause more more problems if we
don't have that language in there
follow up um if you wish
i think i'll let other people ask
questions thank you representative
cushman
thank you mr chairman i don't have a
question
it's okay a statement um
at the end of the day we need to protect
the rights of the patients and if the
hospital can't make those
available in writing
and need to
revoke rights on a whim
it's not acceptable we need to put this
through so that we ensure that patients
have the right to have a caregiver a
designee one person that can be there
with them while they're receiving care
and i am frankly
fatigued by the excuses from the new
hampshire hospital association that that
is not possible and that you need
flexibility to keep family members out
i'm sorry but when people are in the
hospital and they need care they need
their support people with them and this
allows for ppe to be used there are
plenty of mitigation
methods to use but one
visitor in the hospital with a family
member who is probably in one of the
worst situations of their life is
something that they all need
and rep and
representative weber's amendment does
address that and um
i think we're going to agree to disagree
relative to how
hospitals have allowed for caregivers to
be with their loved ones and they have
been making accommodations certainly
with when there's been end of life and
it's just we've been in an extraordinary
circumstance for the last two years so
um
i think we have attempted to the
hospitals have attempted to be
accommodating it's just
there are certain situations that need
to be um considered
representative woods yeah thank you
um
just looking at its overall picture i
i'm really in favor of putting this into
the patient education that's where it's
going to be most visible
and part of this whole process is
education
if it's put in there in the patient's
bill of rights they get that during a
time of admission or it can be a flyer
on the floor right uh but i appreciate
that that it is referenced
in representative leone's bill but
that's
not as has been stated it's not going to
be
something that they're going to be
easily referenced so i think that's very
important secondly
i i too
feel that the
medically and therapeutically
contraindicated is absolutely critical
there has to be a captain of the ship
and it can't be
one family coming in and say i want this
and this is my right and the next
patient is coming in and say well i want
this right
there has to be somebody in charge
and that's one of the response social
responsibilities of physicians we accept
that responsibility
what i'm hearing is we don't trust
physicians
and we only trust written policy
i understand there's going to be some
bad decisions absolutely
but i think we have to understand too
that if we let the public decide
how this is going to occur
um
there's going to be some bad decisions
too
i think i'm just harking back there has
to be a captain of the ship
and we have to decide who we want that
to be
yes there has to be some baseline
policies but trust me you can't
when you go to the emergency room you
can't look the hospital policy about
what you're going to do
you have to act and that's what we're
charged to do
i think keeping that
that
line in about medical and therapeutic
contraindicated is to me
from my perspective as a physician
absolutely critical
representative merchant
thank you mr chairman
i see merits in both of these amendments
um
i do see the
logic of putting in the patient bill of
rights we're talking about the patient
not the visitor
however i do understand with you have a
quote
written hospital policy it does nothing
to preclude the policy
from including the presence of visitors
would be medically therapeutically
contraindicated that could go into the
written policy of the hospital quite
frankly i think that gives the hospitals
a lot of credibility
and a lot of flexibility in what they
want to do with their policy based upon
their needs
versus the state telling them how to run
the facility so i do think that
there's merits in both as i mentioned
one has a place which is a patient bill
of rights we're talking about the
patient not the facility so if really
focus on the patient i think it should
go in the patient's bill of rights
if we're allowing the hospital have the
flexibility to define their policy which
is written it allows them at that point
in time to include pretty much in that
written policy however they want to run
their facility
so i'm looking at the two of them saying
i wish i could have
something between the two i can't
the chair wishes to interject at this
point
and say that this is monday and we're
also meeting tomorrow
you know me i love to square circles
whenever i find them and i don't know if
it's possible but if it's possible to
meld the leon and weber amendment is
there sympathy for that
could i just clarify mr chairman yes
my amendment allows the hospital to have
the policy my amendment authorizes the
hospital to include in the policy
the considerations about presence of
visitors being medically or
therapeutically contraindicated
the leon amendment also allows the
hospital to have their own written
policy they're no different in that
we all agreed on that
but the leon amendment does not
specifically authorize the hospital to
include the issue
of medically or therapeutically
contraindicated
which is a concern for the hospitals
and if you're not concerned about the
hospital's concern then that's not your
concern either i mean other people
wanted to balance things differently
the real
nub here is whether you put that
language in or not in both cases the
hospital gets to draft their policy
but i think that if a hospital drafted a
policy
that
was entirely on the basis that
medically this is contraindicated
and somebody could not visit that that
hospital would be in jeopardy
and if you put it in the licensing
statute i think that hospital would be
in jeopardy of losing their license
that may be far-fetched it may be a
stretch but it's a concern i have
you know i think a lot of us need to go
to the bathroom right now
and as soon as we're done doing that
i think the democrats can have the room
here and the republicans can have the
breakout room over there
and let's do our business and followed
by our business and be back here in
about 10 minutes thank you
representative leon wishes to
[Music]
go get another amendment crafted uh my
30 000 foot down view of it is to pick
up some of the language of
representative weber um i do suggest uh
you you both
chat and we'll see if we can um come up
with something better tomorrow
representative kanark
yes i would just say for efficiency
um although i appreciate that we might
want to wait and get a new amendment
was there any way possible we could just
parse that language so that we actually
submit one that we all like and then we
can just get on with it uh if we if
there's no reason for secrets we try to
work together well and if we wait we
don't see it till tomorrow and we don't
like that then that's a problem we could
try to come together right now
representative weber
and we can all adjust address it here in
an executive session i don't feel
comfortable at this point in the process
starting over with just two people
talking about it i don't speak for
everybody on
on my side and i certainly don't speak
for anybody out there so
if if there is a compromise that you're
considering it would be very helpful to
have it stated
so that we can
indicate immediately whether that's
going to be helpful or not and then
move ahead
representative leon
thank you mr chairman it's it's this is
looking to put back the presence of
visitors being contraindicated with some
guide rails about providing the
reasoning and writing um just so that we
can make sure that those policies are
actually individualized and not just a
quiet hospital policy um need to get the
actual language right but that is the
intent of that amendment representative
merchant
i'll depart the website representative
weber
and would that be put into the patient's
bill of rights or into the licensing
statute
it would be in the licensing statute
it's a non-starter for us
for me personally
if i may why why in the facility versus
the patient's bill of rights we're
talking about the patient here not the
facility i think we're trying to be sure
the patient has their rights
and therefore the facility has to honor
their rights so therefore indirectly it
becomes part of the facility but it's
actually in the right place because
we're talking about patients
not the facility
what's the consequence today for a
hospital not following the patient bill
of rights
ms manahan
miss rogers
so
i i need to actually review the statute
um i'm not you know an expert on exactly
what the consequences are but they are
they can be challenged
that someone can raise it with the
department again it does fall under 151
it's just not a condition of licensure
per se but
the patient bill of rights are posted
and those are available i i think a lot
of hospitals post them um
poster in an actual poster um posted in
their facilities um and they are also
um
posted and uh and given to a patient
when they are admitted to the hospital
so those are their their rights
uh would you have any objection to
moving it up to patients bill of rights
yes i would there's an injection my
objection is there's been a lot of
broken trust and i know a lot of people
who will refuse to go to the hospital
and they would rather die at home than
be denied the opportunity to have their
loved ones with them i know
many many many people
who now are opting out of the medical
system because they have lost this trust
if the hospitals are doing the right
thing on patient visitation then their
licensing won't be at risk the option to
have the written hospital policy for
visitors provides a lot of leeway for
the hospitals and we need to start
rebuilding this trust and if the
hospitals may have some threat against
their licensing if they don't honor
their own policies well i thought that's
why we had policies um so i i won't i
will not support it being solely in the
patient bill of rights because we need
to make sure that those rights aren't
actually enforced
and i'm just going to say i that is a
stunning statement for you to say that
the hospitals need to rebuild their
trust they have been taking care of
patients for the la for
hundreds of years actually and in the
last two years have been under
extraordinary um stress i i am
on behalf of our hospitals and our our
caregivers that that is
a very stunning and upsetting statement
for me to hear you say that
god
i i don't really think i have anything
else to say
represented i think that means we need
to do more to rebuild i have had
hundreds of people share that so once we
get past these sessions hopefully we can
build back those relationships my
suggestion is you go do what you need to
do and we'll do what we need to do
this could go on all day i'm gonna take
three more people and then we're going
to move on representative gay you've
been patient
thank you i just wanted to ask why we
well i shouldn't say it negatively i
would like to say
keep the uh keep the re this stunning
requirement
in
the leon amendment and
make sure it's in the patient bill of
rights too
representative merchant
one of the things he would be getting is
about the licensing there's also
accrediting organizations out there
and haven't worked in hospitals for many
many many years even though it's not a
legal requirement
but the accrediting organizations will
not accredit a facility if they don't
comply to the basics of what's required
of them and one of those is actually the
patient's bill of rights so even though
we don't pull their license if the
accrediting organization does not
accredit them
at that point in time they would lose
the revenue stream so there is a
consequence then for not following the
patient bill of rights
versus just looking at it from a
licensing
so there is in my opinion i don't know
again not an attorney but that's my
understanding is don't forget the
accrediting organizations that are out
there and the impact they have on
facilities and how they follow certain
things because if you lose your revenue
stream from an organization that's going
to be really critical to you
last one representative weber
thank you mr chairman
it's very clear that we have two
different points of view here
it's very clear that we are still going
to have two points of view tomorrow
we have two stat two competing
amendments in front of us
um and and
i will just say
my family and i looked after my husband
at home in his last illness because
that's what he wanted patients make
these
decisions
all the time he didn't want to be in a
hospital he wanted to be in his own bed
and i thank god even though i'm not sure
i believe in one
that we were able to do that for him
but everybody has to make those
decisions
based on their own comfort level and
their understanding of their needs
i think what we should do is just go
ahead and vote the amendments that are
in front of us one way or another and
then go to lunch
the chair is uh going to
rule that representative leon may come
back with an amendment tomorrow
and then we will vote the amendments and
i do not know at this point in which
order
because the first one that is voted in
will be replaced when the second one is
voted in
so this
ends
for now the
hearing on 14
39.
i now open the exact session on house
bill 1244 relative to parental consent
to medical and dental treatments of
children in schools representative
cushman's
bill
and has an amendment
mr chair
yes i have one it's also an amendment to
this which is upstairs under printer
okay
go get it
please
12 44.
you can start by reading the cushman
amendment which is zero four nine nine
you sh should have had been given it
in your direction right now oh and
here's another one just because it's you
ken
yeah because it's you we're going to
give you another one you're welcome you
know try to do our best to our friends
oh i already have one
because we have 23 bills eventually to
do and we've only done three when you
get the amendments please read them
because we will not then not stop for
you to do it do it now please
representative cushman please introduce
your amendment 0499
thank you mr chairman so before us we
have an amendment to this bill that
requires
explicit written consent
from a child's parent or legal guardian
for any treatments in school we expanded
it to
also screenings since we heard testimony
that there were some screenings
performed
that are invasive and
anything that is not
related to education anything that's not
educational in nature that's going on in
public schools should require
a consent from the parents
and the other
major changes that it also inserts that
inserts the language
into
not only the department of health and
human services statutes but also the
education statutes
what line does the education statutes
appear that is section three
under school health services
so okay rsa200 got it thank you
representative merchant your amendment
looks
almost the same
it is almost the same that's why it
looks it
after having some
length conversations with
someone in my family who's been a school
nurse for many years
she did point out that
in regards to treatment it's currently
their policy has been away for a long
time
that you cannot provide any treatment to
a patient or in this case a minor
without the explicit written consent of
the parent
the screenings under the hand become
problematic because a lot of times
it's the absentee parent
that doesn't provide good parental
oversight
that needs to have the attention and
screenings are not treatment this
basically is a screening
picking up on a child's vision
hearing
etc is critical to that child
and i just want to be sure that we talk
about
something that's not invasive
it's strictly a screening
that we're trying to protect the child
from the
off suit if you will
of not having someone taken the time to
sign a form
because vision
is critical hearing is critical you
cannot learn accordingly if you don't
have the two of them along with other
things
so she really advocated on my behalf
which convinced me
to take the word screenings out of this
to allow that to occur without
explicit written consent of the parent a
lot of times parents will probably
provide it
but don't want to have it a requirement
because again go back to the same thing
she said
gary the children who need it the most
are probably the children of being
neglected the most so she said you want
to protect those children because it's
only a screening it's not treatment
for the comments from anyone
representative kanark uh yeah i was
curious can you give an example of an
invasive in quotes screening
uh well yeah dental screenings are very
invasive they enter a body cavity and
especially for kids who have sensory
issues this can be a problem
i would say that any
any screening really because this is an
educational environment
where students are meant to be educated
it is not a
community health clinic
you know it's it's nice to have that
available
but
at the end of the day people send their
kids to school to be educated not to
have medical interventions and
screenings performed so if that's going
to happen there needs to be positive
consent for that representative connor
follow up just a quick follow-up i i
would agree that that would be wonderful
in an ideal world but our public health
system does not exist very well here
which is why we actually also feed
children at schools
and other things because we
unfortunately dump onto our schools a
lot of the things that should be done
elsewhere
and it would be wonderful if everybody
had good health care access so they
would get that screening but they don't
and so it's a stop gap to try to help
backfill
so kids don't get lost in the shuffle
and not able to learn because they can't
hear and they can't see
the chair's comment is i recall in
school
eye tests
hearing tests looking into my mouth
turning my head and coughing
and others i can't think of right now
and we discovered that the ones where
there was uh oh something's wrong here
with the kids who least likely ever went
to medical care
we were an educational and health center
it was called the leominster public
school system representative gay
thank you
my concern i i don't have a problem with
doing the screenings at school
i am i do have a friend who has a child
who has a sensory problem and doesn't
want to be touched and you know they
have
but i'm thinking don't parents
don't parents have to sign a release
at some point at the beginning of school
so there is a time an opportunity for
the parents who
have reservations about certain things
for their child they do have that
opportunity to say
you know i need to be consulted
but
i think it's a good idea to do the
screenings and just allow the exceptions
to be covered by their parents
representative woods you had your hand
up i believe
uh well i'm going to work down the road
don't worry i'll tell you i i just want
to emphasize uh that in fact what uh
representative
mentioned
a medical intervention is providing
lunch
and so and
technically we would have to get
permission to provide lunch
representative merchant
i just wanted to respond to um
representative gay thank you for
understanding what i'm talking about
there's actually a
relatively small set of parents that
don't
provide parental oversight it depends
upon the community depends upon the
economic status and so forth etc i
cannot share with you folks some of the
stories my wife brought home from school
but there are many parents out there who
are very neglectful
and unfortunately we have to have a
backstop with those parents because
those children are critical
and to chairman pearson's point of view
they don't always pay attention to the
medical community they don't even take
the children to the physician they don't
even get wellness visits
what do we do with them we have to
somehow protect them
from the neglect of a parent in having
that point in time
having a school nurse who's been trained
to do the screenings
this is not somebody's a teacher this is
a school nurse who's gone to school
most likely for four years who's been
accredited as a school nurse who
understands how to deal with a child
so we're not talking about just anyone
in the school building doing the
screenings we're talking about people
who are relatively trained to do it so
i'm advocating for those
children
who don't have parents the way we think
of parents today
and help protect them thank you
representative shapiro
yes thank you um
this is a question i'm not sure if this
is intentionally left out or purposely
left out
but one issue
that i'm thinking of is that
currently
children at the age of 14 are able to
consent to
sexually transmitted disease treatment
and diagnosis
i think that's probably irrelevant
because i don't know of any schools that
have like a clinic within the school
although that's possible but i don't
know of any in new hampshire that have
that but in regard to substance use
diagnosis treatment
prevention
there are many many schools that have
people who provide those services in the
school
and um
state law
and i think federally also um those
people are allowed those
children minors are allowed to consent
at the age of 12.
um so this the way this is written it
doesn't make any exception for those
kind of services that happen in schools
and maybe that's intentional maybe you
don't feel like those should be provided
in schools but
that would have an enormous impact
on the schools as they exist today and
what they offer today and also on the
um
changing the access to
substance use disorder
services
representative weber
[Music]
i just had a quick
answer to the concern about the child
with sensory issues which is a very real
concern
first of all as representative merchants
said a trained professional is going to
take those into account in performing a
screening and it may be that the
screening can't be performed for good
and sufficient reason because it would
cause way more harm than it would
but the other remedy for that is that
the parent who is concerned about their
child
writes a note as my mother did at the
beginning of every single school year
which said lucy is not to drink whole
milk
so i didn't i wasn't actually allergic
to it but i hated it so much that i
could blow my cookies every single time
and i had any number of people who
thought they were going to teach me to
drink milk and they were all wrong but
my mother wrote a note and so if a
parent is concerned about a particular
approach to their child which is
inappropriate for their child they write
a note and say don't do it
now this side of the room anybody
representative cushman
thank you mr chairman
so anything that is done to children in
schools i think that is not educational
and isn't part of what parents expect to
be happening to their kids needs to have
consent there is no reason that this
can't be part of the beginning of the
year packet that goes out and the
parents sign all the forms and if they
see the form and they say oh my child
shouldn't have this dental screening we
we you know for whatever reason i don't
want them to have it they should have
that right we can't punish or take away
rights
from parents just because we can't
hear what's going on here please because
of a small
percentage of people who would abuse
that right and if they are medically
neglectful then they should be have
child protective services involved and
the schools can pay attention and and
make that decision to report if it comes
to that
but at the beginning of the year to have
a form in the packet that goes out
it's not it's not a huge ask and it
ensures that parental rights are honored
anyone else over here
okay representative snow
thank you mr chairman i just the
personal story my wife
who grew up in a very middle-class
family with very caring parents
and she when she was in school in first
and second grade
realized that she had to sit in the
front row because she couldn't see
anything on the blackboard unless she
sat in the front row and went up and
that
and the parents had no real inkling that
anything was wrong because the report
was never done
she had a screening and a school nurse
one day came knocking on the front door
of their house
and said you need to take your daughter
to an eye doctor she really has a
deficient
vision the mother was very embarrassed
they immediately took it she's worn
glasses ever since
and thank the lord they did the
screening
i remember she tried out for the
softball team
never did see a ball in the air she said
she just swung and hoped somehow she
came within close proximity
but i i think in many cases
and i think to have those forms put in
the
in the folder at the beginning of the
year
those same parents that don't do it are
not going to sign those forms either so
the people that need the screening
the most but there are people from
families like my wife's family
who benefited greatly from having that
screening and done
at school thank you
i have a story his name is eddie
and we all knew eddie was deaf his
parents didn't
and one day eddie got the hearing test
screening
that we all did
and a note went home
you ought to go get your kids
professionally
ear hearing
we don't think he can hear
and the parents weren't bad they weren't
angry
they were just clueless
until the note went home
and eddie was fitted up with hearing
aids and
he could finally hear the teacher and do
better in school
that was the screening
they didn't the school didn't make him
get hearing aids the school sent home a
note
saying this is something we in the
learning process
you'd send your kids to school to learn
if they're not learning why is that
there's a diagnostic thing for dyslexia
is that invasive
no johnny can't read why is that
screenings
not treatments
so another hand representative
wave off okay
so let me ask our parliamentarian
the protocol here i was under the
impression
um if an amendment is adopted and then
the next amendment is adopted and both
replace of the same thing the first one
goes away i want to do this right and
this is new to me
what normally happens is each person
decides which amendment that they
appre approve
they're competing amendments
each of us has one we prefer
if
each of us decides which one we prefer
and vote yes or not to pass on that and
no on
itl on the ones they want to keep
it comes out right because we should not
be voting for two
voting the same way for two amendments
if the amendments are competing what
i've seen happening in the if it happens
i don't know what happens i suppose the
last in time controls but
my concern is
i don't see why anybody would vote yes
on two different competing amendments
what we have done at some points in the
past
is we've had an amendment that amends
the first paragraph of a bill and
everybody agreed that that made the bill
better and then we've had a second
amendment that changes paragraph 12 of
the bill and everybody like that and ols
can just put those two together into a
committee amendment at the end but we
have before us i would urge people to
vote
ought to pass an itl rather than not to
pass on everything because that's way
lies so if i
understand i could ask and it doesn't
matter which order
representative merchant will move otp
and then we'll count the votes and then
representative cushman or in the other
order would move otp and
the amendment
yeah on the amendment each amendment and
those who want representative cushmans
would write yeah do yes and we hope one
would come out one way and one would
come out the other yes
okay i got representative cushman's
amendment in my midst beforehand uh let
me get my
uh cheat sheet here this is house bill
representative cushman's amendment 0 4 9
9 and representative cushman for a
motion
thank you mr chairman i'm move that we
adopt
amendment zero four nine nine h to house
bill one two four four and the second is
to representative delay miss
and would the clerk please call the role
on amendment 0499
to house bill 1244.
representative leon yes representative
mcmahon
representative acton
representative gay
representative cushman yes
representative folsom yes representative
kelsey
no
representative king
representative co-fault yes
representative delemus
representative weber
representative mckay
representative snow no representative
knurk no representative query
representative cannon
representative nutter upham no
representative shapiro
representative woods no representative
merchant
representative pearson no
the amendment is defeated 14 to 7. the
chair recognizes representative merchant
for
a motion
make a motion to introduce
to house bill
1244 amendment
nine 2022-0979h
and is there a second representative
pearson seconds that
and when the chair is ready please call
the roll on the merchant amendment zero
nine seven nine to house bill 1244 moved
by representative merchant seconded by
the chair
thank you for the promotion to chair
you just promoted me to chair why did i
do that
when you asked me to call the roll okay
you want to swap seats no
i used to do that job i know you did
okay i know you did that was only to
separate me from
yeah well they need to separate us
sometimes um who's the common one in
this i ask
sorry
okay back to back to business okay um
representative leon yes
representative mcmahon
representative acton
representative gay
representative cushman yes
representative folsom yes representative
kelsey representative king
yes representative cole fault yes
representative delemus
representative weber
representative freitas
representative snow yes representative
knurk yes representative query
yes representative cannon yes
representative nutter upham yes
representative shapiro yes
representative woods yes representative
merchant yes representative pearson yes
passes 21 21 to zip now the chair will
entertain somebody who would like to uh
make a motion ought to pass as amended
i'll make the emotion
a representative merchant will make the
uh motion and i would like to see
a second from this side over here
representative cushman of course
the motion is ought to pass as amended
by um amendment zero nine seven nine
this is house bill 1244 moved by
representative merchants second by
representative cushman
one moment
representative leon
yes representative mcmahon
representative acton
representative gay
representative cushman yes
representative folsom yes representative
kelsey representative king yes
representative cofoult yes
representative delemus
representative weber
representative freitas yes
representative snow
representative knurk yes representative
query
yes representative cannon yes
representative nutter upham yes
representative shapiro no
representative woods yes representative
merchant
representative pearson
yes
20 to 1 passes
consent
any objection to consent
representative merchants i will
be very happy to receive your most
excellent uh committee report thank you
and since it's going on consent there
will not need to be another report
written thank you
okay
um
i know of at least one member who needs
to be out briefly at one o'clock so my
plan is to push through till about
12 30 or so
and then have a slightly late
lunch break
um
okay let's try number 1633
slam dunk
uh you are icloud
rtl um
and the box goer in 1244
was in its original form
579 supported and 156 were against
now let's uh since we're moving to 1633
the um box score on this
in favor of requiring covert vaccination
for school attendance
and writing in against 2929.
you asked
i didn't know that many people could
write
chair recognizers representative lay on
for a motion on 1633.
thank you mr chairman and i move in
expedient to legislate on house bill
1633 and the second where i represent
i'll second that
is it
that's your
merchant oh okay okay we'll accept
other side of the playground okay
and uh
would you like me to speak to the motion
sure okay um i think if we recall the
testimony department of health and human
services at this point has no would has
no intention to add the covet 19
vaccination because there's no consensus
therefore this bill is at best premature
and i believe that we should vote it an
expedient to legislate i will second
those comments
anybody else
representative shapiro
yes i would um
also suggest that we itl this bill i
think that
um we're best off when consensus drives
law making and um not when lawmaking
drives consensus and um
as indicated by the sign ins and as
indicated by a lot of controversy about
this we don't have a consensus on this
issue
so i think we should
itl the bill
anybody else
great idea thank you i was thinking of
that
so
we are going to vote
moved by leon and recommended and
seconded by merchant
itl on house bill 1633
would the clerk please
call the roll representative leon yes
representative mcmahon representative
acton yes representative gay
representative cushman yes
representative folsom yes representative
kelsey yes representative king
yes representative kofalt yes
representative delemus
representative weber
representative freitas
representative snow yes representative
knurk yes representative query
representative cannon yes representative
nutter upham yes representative shapiro
representative woods yes representative
merchant
yes representative pearson
yes and who gets to ask me to ask the
question
that i always forget
consent shall we put this on consent
would you like this to go on consent
yes and if she hasn't already done so
with the vice chair please write the
blurb
we have blurbs for sale by the way we
spent some time writing a whole bunch of
them some of which will never get used
but
okay
good 21 to zip
this ends the
exec session
on 1633
and i would like now to open the exact
session on 1044
and this is kind of uh
what astronomers call a binary star as
it eventually evolved they rotate around
each other
1044 with an amendment that's coming and
1347 with an amendment that is coming
are very very similar
and so i will call on representative
um cushman
who is the mother of these two
amendments
and um speak to the one on 10 44 and
then right after that 137 47 ought to go
quickly
thank you mr chairman
the amendment you have before you
you will see
i'm sorry
that you will have before you
um it is called
907.
we'll give everybody a few minutes to
read it
you
representative leon would you please
introduce
cushman representative cushman like it
says right in front of me thank you
you're welcome um
so
uh amendment
22-0
this
so we weren't sure on the um
what kind of model but we are sure that
we need an alternative option for health
care in new hampshire so
it includes membership based business
models
the amendment does and
the direct pay only facilities
it also we needed to incorporate
something into the patient bill of
rights because as it stands the patient
bill of rights for medical facilities
licensed under 151
colon 2
it has a few mentions of medicare and
medicaid and
not
not discharging based on
source of payment so those obviously
wouldn't apply to these direct payment
and membership based business model
facilities
so
similar to the home health
agency
bill of rights
they are exempt from
the
[Music]
current patient bill of rights for
medical facilities and have their own
bill of rights which is is exactly the
same except it removes those five lines
that have to do with medicare medicaid
and insurance
representative webber
thank you and um
having
looked at it i understand the need for
the difference there but i am
first of all very concerned that this
bill which was only originally about
uh
payment for
a facility that operates on a membership
basis
suddenly we are incorporating the
patient's bill of rights and that was
something that was done with no notice
to the public or operators of a facility
that might want to operate under these
things and i'm not at all
sure that it's a germane amendment to
begin with
it troubles me that there has been no
opportunity for public comment on it in
any case
but i think that the concerns that
a number of people expressed on a
membership basis business model
continue to be
i mean i think the drafting may be a
little better than than the original
drafting but i think that the concerns
of the people who opposed the original
bill
are still going to
hold good for this
these are the sorts of
facilities that siphon off
patients who can pay from facilities
that are operating on the edge and
i think that that
given that we
can't change the whole thing right now i
think it's fine that somebody wants to
operate on a membership-based business
model but i think they ought to be
subject to the same rules as everybody
else so i'm
opposed to the amendment and opposed to
the
underlying bill representative merchant
thank you
the other concern i have in here there's
no requirement for them to submit data
to the new hampshire department of
health
so the department of insurance to
provide transparency
all the other facilities are going to be
required to do that number two
when you look at things today a patient
can actually go on site
and find the cash payment
by any facility for any service they
provide including by the way dental
services
is an interesting site to go to it's
very robust has a tremendous amount of
data there so a patient today can
actually
be proactive
look at what the procedure is if they
have a high deductible and decide where
they want to get it done
so therefore i think we already have
free market competition in this market
today i support free market i think it's
the way we always try to bring
transparency and pricing down but i
believe today we have a system in place
that is in fact very transparent
that the patients can utilize
and to their advantage and therefore
once we educate them on how to do that
we actually in
fact open up competition in the
marketplace because we educate patients
on where to get the information
representative cushman
thank you mr chairman
representative merchant first
you're incorrect that they do not have
to submit information to the department
this bill only
alters
section paragraph 1 of 151 colon 2
dash f
and
the relevant pieces that you're talking
about are in
a different section of the law they are
in
just gonna find um
i'm in the wrong section i'm sorry
here it is uh section two they must
adopt publicize and apply assistance
plan so they still have to have
assistance plans um this is rep mark
mclean's bill and it never altered that
requirement um they also need to in
paragraph three of that section of of
the rsa is they need to provide data to
the commissioner of the department of
health and human services regarding the
volume cost and outcomes of services
provided in the facilities and they need
to pay the fees um for licensing
so they still do have to do everything
that other facilities have to do except
take all forms of payment and we've seen
that the requirement to accept all forms
of payment has become very onerous and
controversial because
cms is included in that and we have seen
mandates and regulations that many
businesses do not agree with many
consumers do not agree with and
currently in new hampshire there are no
alternative options and we need to allow
for those options to spring up let the
market work because right now it is a
closed market that is only open to those
who accept cms
representative connerk
um a couple of things i would like to
echo what representative weber said
before basically again
particularly if we look at our critical
access hospitals they function on razor
thin margins
the yes indeed there is cost shifting
that's how they stay afloat you made
representative cushman made a very good
set of arguments when she presented
about how broken her health care system
is a good argument for why we need to
reform it perhaps need a single-payer
system
but this is not the way to do it because
it simply will not work we can look back
to a time when we did have a much a
little bit more free market
and older people couldn't get health
care because who's going to who's going
to insure somebody
who is old and poor
they're not a good risk or just poor
because it's not going to work
and that is why we had
medicare and medicaid get formulated
because it made more sense letting these
people simply die in the streets which
is what was happening
now
this
is going to suction off
siphon off
the paying patients particularly from
our critical access hospitals and we
have seen closure of maternity wards
because that's a that's a loss leader
for them
and they cannot afford to continue to do
it
uh the rate of births in uh
by police increased on laconia when they
closed their birthing center these are
real impacts these are i live in a place
where there's not a lot of choices for
medical care
and if you put a birthing center there
it's gonna it's gonna close memorial
hospital or it's to siphon off any of
the ones that do pay and they're going
to have to just drop it
but i'm also very troubled by the fact
that i think this is does have a great
deal that's not germane it adds an
enormous amount to this bill including a
whole separate patient bill of rights
for the
direct pay and membership based
and actually interestingly enough
because of the fact you're describing
that so to remove
them
we have the uh
the patient i should it's actually the
point i'm getting at is there's a lot
here to try to
look at it's not a simple amendment on
section five of the original bill of
rights
it says that if you
suddenly go on medicaid because perhaps
you've spent down your assets which
happens to many people they can just
throw you out in the street
unless you are required to take medicaid
payment which is of course the major
source of our payment
and
i'm trying to see in your number five
and the new bill of rights
or for non-payment for the state patient
stay
so it says that the patient can be
discharged
for non-payment of stay
so and they don't accept medicare or
medicaid so that means if a person now
is spent down their assets
they're in a nursing home we're going to
throw them on the street
so i would say that this bill goes
beyond first of all siphoning off
health care
from our critical access hospitals
leaving them to
get into financial trouble to being just
downright wrong
we've just received an opinion from the
clerk of the house that this amendment
may not be germane
that's what i'd say
i'm not sure if we need any further
discussion on it
well it's the speaker's purview so maybe
we should ask him
okay
that will be my job
so if you could excuse me for a few
minutes
so i don't tie you all up i'm going to
um
postpone
move close
recess the hearing on this so over your
lunch hour i can speak with the speaker
this will be on 10 44 and probably
therefore 13.47
and uh just while i remember the
information representative shapiro likes
to know this
two bits of information sign in on the
original bill 1044 the number was 417-4
and 3 against
but a year ago when pretty similar to
this came to here it was 18 to 3 itl so
there's your numbers
so i will deal with that over the lunch
hour
and
um
top of my stack here is
open the hearing to uh the executive
session
to
repealing the statute
relative to medical freedoms in
immunizations
the representative horrigan's
bill
and while i've got my sheet here
and 119 signed in in favor of his bill
in 362
signed in against 14
and
uh somebody
has already
signed
to do this so i uh the chair calls on
representative erica leon for a motion
um thank you mr chairman i move and
expedient to legislate on house bill
1481 and do i have a second
yes i second thank you discussion
thank you mr chairman
this bill seeks to repeal the
protections that are in statute about
people's choices around vaccination
without informed consent
treatments are
unethical
the what we need to do to increase
vaccination rates is to convince people
of the science the data and the
protection not to coerce them by
limiting their access to public public
accommodations to schools or to any
other services
that is not the way to build public
health to respect people's rights and to
get
people's
enthusiastic cooperation
the way we do that is by having data
following that data
and
not mandating things when we heard when
we had the committee to study
intervention medical interventions and
immunizations we heard from many many
people we also realized at that time
that as soon as the mandate started
coming down the vaccination rate started
tailing off
once people were being forced to be
vaccinated they were wondering what they
were missing
if you have to force me to do this
is this really in my best interest and
that actually caused i believe caused a
decline in the acceptance rate of the
vaccinations um i'm thankful that we
have this statute in place i think that
it is critical because
discrimination for a medical choice is
wrong no matter what medical choice that
is it is wrong and therefore i believe
that we need to keep the statute as it
stands and
itl this bill
representative shapiro
thank you um i will be
voting ought to pass for this bill and
um small picture
um i think it's a problem that the
statute as it currently exists
does not include an exception for public
universities and public colleges which
have congregate living the same way that
nursing homes and state-run hospitals
like glencliff
and
new hampshire hospital have they both
have that in common
um dorm living congregate living
hospital living and yet one was accepted
from this act and the other was not so
that's a small picture of um
something in the statute that i disagree
with but larger picture
you know i think there have just been
um
not
one bill not two bills and not
scores of bills really
which are promoting
ideas about
privacy
personal liberty
um choice
i understand these bills but i think the
bills that have been coming to us
day after day after day are so heavily
weighted in terms of
personal issues
at the
end and
where is the concern about
the common good where is the concern
about
public health
i think that
we have just tipped the scales in terms
of
privacy personal liberty choice
and
we are not taking into consideration
the greater good for the greater number
of people i mean i think a
lot of the things that we decide here
have
dueling
goods
and i think that we are way over on the
side
of um
we we have we we talked earlier or
somebody talked um representative leon
talked about trust
and i think these
bills one after another after another in
my mind are what's building this
distrust
so
um
i don't think we need the spill i mean i
don't think we need the statute and so
i'm going to vote ought to pass
representative acton
thank you mr chair
a lot of the
a lot of these bills are pushed back in
response to what we've been through
so
they don't they didn't just materialize
out of thin air
a lot of it's based on what what we've
endured through covet
and it's been intense it's been a lot of
loss of liberties
one thing after another and we've hit a
brick wall here as far as the
the uh department and the
the associations and the lobbyists
groups and so forth in in
opposing what the majority of lease is
trying to do so
yes we have a lot of bills and we all
notice that
um some of them tend to be a little bit
knee-jerk in reaction we're working
through that but these were not just
brought out of thin air they they
happened because they're
they're our response to what we feel is
uh overplaying of of your hand by by the
uh the medical system
that's it
representative merchant i'm going to
take a different tack on this
if we repeal this
statute
then we're also at the same time
repealing the ability for a nursing home
to require a vaccine
so in essence it's not just the question
of looking at repealing it
from the patient's right
per se
but it's also appealing the fact that we
carved out of here exceptions to this
and if we repeal that all those
exceptions go by the wayside
and i'm concerned about those exceptions
not being there
for all the reasons why they were there
in the first place
so i'm taking a different tack on this
and saying
i'm against repealing it because i want
to protect
those that were excluded so that they
are being able to be protected in some
of those vulnerable places we have
representative canarch
those exceptions were put in
because of this act
those exceptions if this act goes away
those exceptions are still there the
nursing homes prior to this act were
allowed to mandate vaccinations which
they do for any number of other diseases
the only reason because when 220 came
initially which is what this bill was
last year
it did not have these exceptions and we
realized that this was going to cause
any number of issues such as for example
you couldn't involuntarily commit
somebody for mental health treatment
when they're suicidal
so that was carved out as exception
the exceptions are there because of this
bill
there's if this bill goes away the
exceptions aren't needed because they
were already in practice so that's not a
problem
yeah that's enough said
yeah just and plus also we saw in 1604
uh you know rolling that back anyway
losing that exception so
that's that's these it's perfectly
reasonable just get rid of it we aren't
going to be in trouble with it
seeing no further questions
ask the clerk to call the roll
on house bill 1481
sorry
sorry yes sorry on
the yes the motion is itl on house bill
1481.
representative leon yes representative
mcmahon
representative acton yes representative
gay
representative cushman yes
representative folsom yes representative
kelsey yes representative king yes
representative cofoult yes
representative delemus
representative weber
representative freitas no representative
snow representative knurk no
representative query
representative gannon
representative nutter upham no
representative shapiro no representative
woods
no representative merchant yes
representative pearson
yes
i'll take it back the bill uh the motion
itl
succeeds 12 to nine therefore the bill
is
killed and with the vice chair please
write the committee blurb
and who wishes to write the minority
report
representative shapiro thank you so much
we'll try one more and if it takes
longer than
long um
we'll just stop
that uh ends the executive's session on
house bill 1481 and i open the executive
session on house bill 1455.
the prime sponsor is representative
packard
and it is relative to state enforcement
of federal
vaccination mandates and while i think
about it
there were 513 people signing in in
favor of it and 98
against we had
thought there might be some amendments
but eventually the
conclusion which the speaker agreed with
is just a straight up bill
this is the bill
and um
as the chairman of the speaker's bill i
recognize myself for a motion and i move
out to pass and that is being seconded
by
representative cushman now let's discuss
representative canuck
well
i'm sorry
oh i know i would but i'm doing three
things
so
who would like to speak for
representative cushman you seconded it
so we have here representative packard's
bill we decided no amendments are needed
and we want to say to the federal
government that new hampshire is going
to do things the way new hampshire is
going to do things and we are not going
to be blackmailed by the federal
government and we will not enforce the
federal government's
dictates
that
we need to mandate vaccinations or
comply with that so we're not going to
send any information to them
and
other states have sanctuary
policies for
immigrants and when it comes to
enforcement of immigration laws and if
those can apply there then this one can
apply here
that's what i was going to say
representative knurk yes thank you very
much um
once again we're back to the same
arguments that were made in 1604 we do
have uh this will interfere with the
ability of our hospitals for example and
including our nursing homes at the
county level which are political
subdivisions
uh to be able to set their own policies
or to to actually in this particular
case to
follow the policies of the cms mandates
which will put their funding at risk and
i know that the argument keeps being
made that the
it hasn't happened yet in other states
but to remember that it is a new
requirement and the first steps are to
first determine that the person at the
hospital i'm sorry is out of compliance
after that are warning letters the
ability to remediate that lack of
compliance and on and on down the line
before payment is withheld and again the
supreme court though it was a stay of an
injunction there have been no appeals
filed yet against that injunction
and their language is perfectly clear
and in the cms rules it states clearly
that if states pass other rules that
they are uh
that the cms mandate rides over that due
to the supremacy clause
that's in the rules and that they've
also given that
that uh that's what i want to say
guidance
so with all that in mind this gives us
the same problem we had with 1604
it puts us at risk and particularly for
the nursing homes and for the hospitals
of funding and that's not a matter of
blackmail
it is a matter of following proper
medical
care proper medical care is to not undo
the
cause a patient have an undue
exposure to a communicable disease that
they don't need to face they have enough
risks when they come in the hospital
from the things that
people like gary woods and i do to them
they don't have to face things that they
don't have to face
and there are a lot of various
guidelines that are set
uh by
cms and by accrediting agencies for what
needs to be done to make sure that
proper standards are followed whether
it's
central line insertion whether it's
infection rates uh vaccinations any
number of things
and it is a matter of complying with
that not for blackmail but for the best
medical care
so i would vote
against this ought to pass
any further discussion
the motion before us
is house bill 1455
ought to pass moved by the chair
seconded by representative cushman
with the clerk please
call the roll
representative leon yes representative
mcmahon
representative acton yes representative
gay
representative cushman yes
representative folsom yes representative
kelsey yes representative king yes
representative cofolt yes representative
delemus representative weber
representative freitas no representative
snow no representative knurk no
representative query
no
representative cannon no representative
nutter upham no representative shapiro
no
representative woods no representative
merchant
no
representative pearson yes eleven to ten
eleven two ten
the bill passes
representative kinork will do the
minority report
and i'm assuming itl
yeah yeah minority opinion is itl thank
you and we'll find some
guy off the street to write the
committee report
okay this uh closes house bill 1455
before we break for lunch the speaker
has ruled
non-germaine the amendment to 1044.
we are asking him
for a further ruling on
the amendment 937 for house bill 1347
because they're very similar
so with that um come on back by about we
will
resume at 20 past one
now i gotta go next door
yeah susan sure
this is completely none oh
i know
golly in free
until i announce it
i think we're doing really well out of
23 bills we've got six of them done huh
that means we might even get well no
we're going to be there on thursday okay
well we hope so
allowing time for blurbs to be written
please um i almost said turn in your
hymnals
please
i don't think so
which which hymnal did you want us to
use
the lutheran one representative
okay well i've yeah but i don't have it
here with me though
we'll discuss that
please turn
to house bill 1606
making
the
state vaccine registry an opt-in
program
and we have
an amendment authored by
chiefly authored by with help
representative merchant it will be 8 50
and it's coming around
eight i'm sorry
i i didn't hear you
and you have zero nine one nine that's
coming around
oh joy
do we have that one
mr chair
representative merchant um there was
also an amendment that representative
lang created
is that up for discussion or we're just
going to work on this one
it's not being introduced right
it is not
he's waved it off it's official
because there's two that you've passed
out before
so i want to know if we're basically
going to not
consider them or
move to the one withdrawn them he will
draw them thank you sir
did i slam the gavel
yeah
i think so well pretend it did
did everybody have an 850 yes
and here's the next one
the only amendments you need are 850 and
representative lange's two amendments
are withdrawn
and mr chairman if i may with permission
from
president representative merchant thank
you mr chair
if with permission of
representative cushman kelsey in the
woods i'd like to withdraw
zero eight five zero h
and only discuss amendment
zero nine one nine do the co-sponsors
agree
yes i see
yes okay it's withdrawn
we're down to one amendment
and the question was what was the
difference between the two the creek the
critical piece was a phrase at the end
on line 13
which basically says at a point in time
to participate in a registry and also
our illustrious representative cushman
who's our english major here
determined that there was a
calmer after forum that needed to be
inserted so i want to say thank you and
by the way even though my name came
first it was not my by myself it was a
collective
effort by all four of us and i want to
say thank you to all the other people
who worked with us on it to circle the
square
i love it when a plan comes together
would somebody care to speak to 1606
amendment 919 what does it do
although representative cushman wishes
to do it
sure
so this amendment
takes the uh
the intent of the bill and there were
some questions whether we should
you know write out a form that can be
passed out and it was decided among us
that it would be best to not have a form
and statute for this
and rather in section two a
um
it it clarifies that it is that each
patient
or a parent or guardian if the patient
is a minor are given the opportunity to
opt out or opt in
and
that
only
vaccines that are administered shall be
entered into the registry
and that patients shall be able to
receive a
print out of their vaccination records
if they request it from the provider
and then
section b
just clarifies
and strengthens that
um opt-in or opt-out option to
require positive consent for the
information to go in
any questions or comments
nope i think one of the things which was
important this came actually from
an interesting gentleman in my life i
mean a lady in my life uh who's also
school nurse and he said what's in it
for the patient
and she said at that point in time
it'd be nice if you actually could allow
the patient or the parent to go down to
a provider and get a print out of the
vaccine registry
the history if you will so if they want
to go to a summer camp if they want to
go to a transport another school and so
forth they don't have to maintain the
vaccine registry themselves they can
actually go down to a provider and ask
for that print out so she's basically
said focus sometimes of what's in a
patient always what's in it for the
provider
strong patient advocate representative
knurk
i think this is really minor and we
don't want to change it but it's a
interesting wording
on lines nine and eight nine and ten
that they may receive a print out of all
vaccines in the registry i think what
you really mean is all of their
vaccinations in the registry otherwise
this would be that they could get a
printout of the list of vaccines that
are in the registry or everybody's
records which we don't want
and i don't think that's what you mean i
know that's not what you mean i'm just
trying to figure out whether we really
have to worry about the wording or is
this clear enough and implicit in what
we're doing
the lawyer says it's okay fine
and the senate maybe will fix it
representative shapiro
yes thank you
mr chairman um
in my in my thinking
this
amendment
this bill
really
changes the vaccine
registry from an opt out to an opt-in
program and
we heard testimony
from various people including department
of health and human services i believe i
don't want to speak for them that this
would
be onerous for
for providers offices
and also that it would decrease the
number of people who actually
participated in the vaccine registry
which would make it a less robust and
less useful
program
of course nobody can predict how much it
will decrease the participation and you
know it may be 3 percent or it may be 20
nobody can predict that we will see i
guess um but i'm going to vote against
this because of those two issues
representative woods
uh thank you
we considered all of those and came to
the conclusion that with the opt-in
opt-out
that would perhaps
perhaps
uh if we kept it strictly as an opt-in
there perhaps would be as much as three
percent loss is
as an estimate and other people may have
a more rigorous number
um
that balanced against uh the issue that
if it was
a opt-in opt-out
people could still get the vaccine
okay
but not be in the regime not have their
data into the registry that would
increase
the number
as the bill reads
the
even though you
opt out in terms of having your name and
serial number in the registry
the provider whoever provides the
vaccination can still provide an
unidentifiable number in other words
providing 10 vaccines on a given day and
here's seven or eight of the names and
serial numbers and i have three that are
just
vaccinations so that preserves
the public health aspect as much as
possible
so
it seems that this was a nice balance
between the people who wanted to
not
have their name in the registry but
still participate and get a vaccine
and that's really what we're after
the risk was that if in fact it was a
total mandatory opt in there would be a
finite number
unknown that would say um i think i'll
just skip the vaccine entirely
because i don't want my name in the
registry and therefore you miss that
number
so
balancing all those factors it seemed
like the smartest thing to do
that would
give the greatest
balance between
what everybody wanted in their privacy
but at the same time preserving the
ability to make good public health
decisions
representative kelsey thank you mr
chairman i would also like to add i feel
like we incentivized the registry by
adding the portion where patients can
now obtain their records having a child
in school having a child that has gone
to summer camp
that is extremely
convenient for the patients so i would
like to add that i think that that
incentivized the registry
representative gay
thank you i just have a question i'm i'm
thrilled with this amendment um
do do we have to specify that we report
the count that's great to have it do we
have to say that in the bill
you know it's not in the bill what
happens is when a provider uses state
vaccine or vaccine for the safe program
in order for them to replace that
vaccine through safe program they have
to notify the state how many vaccines
they gave not who they gave it to
but i gave 10
and therefore those 10 go to the state
program in order for them to replace the
10.
they maybe there's only nine in there
that have a name in the registry but
they have to tell the state how many
they gave so they can get replacement of
it
seeing no further discussion the motion
before us is
seeing one person before us
does
given it says for each administered
vaccine that would mean that the
provider would need to do this
if they're getting three vaccines in one
visit because it doesn't it says for the
vaccine not for any event of being in
the office to get a vaccination or even
if it's a series
and likewise is it that every time that
they're gonna have a vaccine they have
to go through this even though they've
already done it before just thinking of
the work burden for the office can you
clarify how that works
i can um the forum when it's created
it can list multiple vaccines at one
time so you're not filling up multiple
forms
number two in the workload in the queue
and i did talk to some providers about
this
in the electronic medical record the way
they go through the process is a
checklist that they go through so you
can at that point in time in the
software create a check box
yes or no as far as the
information go into the registry so
therefore from the provider's point of
view it should not be an
additional burden to them because it's
just going down through a checklist
seeing no hands
and hearing of no hands
now
we are going to vote
on the emotion we're going to have a
motion to vote
and the chair recognizes
representative
cushman
to make a motion
would representative merchant like
oh okay
all right
uh mr chairman i move that we adopt
uh amendment 22 2022.
h2 house bill 1606.
and who named representative merchant
would like to second it i will second
that i thought he would thank you that's
what my script says we have to do it
are we ready
by silence
on amendment 919 to house bill 1606
moved by representative cushman seconded
by representative merchant would the
clerk please call the role
representative leon yes representative
mcmahon representative acton yes
representative gay
representative cushman yes
representative folsom yes representative
kelsey yes representative king yes
representative cofolt
yes representative
representative delemus
representative weber
representative freitas yes
representative snow
representative knurk yes representative
query
yes representative cannon yes
representative nutter upham yes
representative shapiro no
representative woods yes representative
merchant yes representative pearson yes
20 to 1 on the amendment 20 to 1 and
there's a very good reason why this
won't go on consent
you know what it is
it's only the amendment
and now the bill before us
and i have
representative kelsey what is your
motion
thank you mr chairman i um ask that we
move ought to pass on house bill 1606
and who over here would like to second
it representative woods
this is the bill is amended
sorry odd to pass as amended on house
bill 1606
like my wife says i try to listen to
what you mean
yeah
we interpret it and write it down
correctly
oh yeah
any further discussion
we're good
hm
representative woods
the bill before us with the motion of
octopass's amendment mended is house
bill 1606 amended by
2022-0919 moved by representative kelsey
seconded by representative woods
would the chair please call the roll
representative leon yes representative
mcmahon representative
yes representative gay
representative cushman yes
representative folsom yes representative
kelsey yes representative king yes
representative cofoult yes
representative delemus representative
weber
representative freitas yes
representative snow yes representative
knurk yes representative query
yes representative cannon yes
representative nutter upham yes
representative shapiro no representative
woods yes representative merchant yes
representative pearson yes
passes 20 to 1.
now there's something you remind me at
this point remember what it is
any objection to consent
so it is on consent and representative
kelsey because you
made the motion
you are rewarded the blurb writing prize
i think um i think representative
merchant wanted to write that blurb
the one that makes the motion gets the
right to burp sorry uh
not necessarily
[Music]
i'll let ladies go first
what are we up to now seven bills we've
done wow
eight
oh my gosh
that ends the
exec session on house bill 1606 and i
open the exact session on house bill 11
and even though i've been practicing it
all week i'll get the word wrong
off
falmick
yeah ophthalmic wow ophthalmic all fun
that's 11 39 and we have
before us i have before me and you will
have before you
the amendment
authored by representative merchants
you guys
[Laughter]
and just for the record pupillary
distance has nothing to do with how
close students sit together
an eye roll would have been sufficient
my granddaughter is really good at that
hmm
what is this
this is
two oh we do have another one all right
you're going to get another one
here comes the others are coming
some of these are not being presented
let the chair announce what we're going
to be looking at
and that is zero eight six seven which
you are in the process of getting from
representative leon and representative
zero nine six three that you have
already gotten from representative
merchants
seems so
people larry
so
you
um
um um
if it doesn't sound like it's gonna fly
there's no
all right the chair recognizes
representatively on about um
an issue in the drafting incorrect
drafting of the amendment
and that will help her get a sense of
where she would like to go forward
thank you mr chairman
after hearing all that we heard i had
read through the wrong amendment the
blue amendments that they had proposed
and i liked everything except for
making and a thalamus bring in a second
professional in order to get the
intrapupillary distance my intention in
drafting this was to take both of their
amendments and simply strip out that
interpupillary distance
if there is sufficient interest to move
this forward without the interpupillary
distance but clarifying the
prescriptions i can get this redrafted
correctly
but if we're looking if we're looking
more towards this merchant amendment and
making sure that we are in fact going to
require intrapupillary distance then i
don't need to redraft this right now
this deletes
section two and three
of the original bill because it was
drafted as a replace all and i apologize
for missing that
so let's discuss what representative
leon has posed to us whether she needs
to go forward or we don't think so um
chair recognizes representative canark
so i'm a little bit confused what you're
saying is
the amendment as you drafted it is not
what you intended because you did intend
to still keep in
section
three of the original bill
or not i'm really confused as to
what you intended and what you're
thinking you might want to do can you
clarify that for me please
yes and i apologize i actually have a
terrible migraine today so it's always
great to swim through mud um well we
passed that we it'll that bill
having migraines
if you can outlaw migraines that make me
happy actually you are correct because
there would be no changes in two and
three right so because we strike
interpupillary distance it doesn't need
to be amended
okay i'm new to this i'd rather call out
my possible mistakes than miss them so
just to clarify so so in other words
your intention was to not
your intention is to not mandate
interpullary distance measurement is
that correct yes that is my intention
i'm with you
call it housekeeping and declare victory
so your pleasure is to do what uh my
pleasure is we go ahead and discuss it
since i don't have a drafting error in
fact
okay we can discuss representative leon
let us know what your amendment is about
thank you mr chairman my amendment is to
keep the areas that were brought up
about making sure that private label and
brand name lenses can be substituted for
each other if as long as they're the
same manufacturer that substitutions are
just for health reasons
and basically to give a little bit more
more power for consumers to shop around
without requiring one professional to
bring a second professional in to write
a prescription
that's really that really was my
challenge because
if it was something that was done in the
regular course of business for the
optometrist um
ophthalmologist
if the professional writing the
prescription if it was part of their
standard practice yes please put that on
but if they have to bring another
professional in i don't think that
that's fair
representative knurk
and i very much
appreciate that and agree because
the bottom line is there's really two
steps the with the ophthalmologist or
optometrist because they're both doing
very much the same type of thing they're
doing the refraction they're saying and
that's why they call it a prescription
for a spectacle lens it's a prescription
for the lens and that tells you what the
refractive power is if you have an
astigmatism what the cylindrical
correction is the axis of that
cylindrical uh a prism if you're going
to be having it because you have eyes
that don't line up all that kind of
stuff
that's for the lens and that doesn't
matter whether you have one eye two eyes
whether they're this far apart or above
each other that's a prescription to
correct each eye that's why there's a
prescription for od and for o l
no yeah anyway so the thing is
that's the prescription then yeah oh wes
sinistra yeah sorry i forgot to go to
the latin dextra and sinister so anyway
the that's the prescription for the lens
the next phase is fitting and that's a
totally separate phenomena
fitting is saying you've got a there's
your spectacles could be big they could
be little like these then you want to
make sure they fit well for where the
eyeballs are placed on the head and
where the patient wishes to place them
if i place these up here or if i place
them down here that's a fitting issue
and
basically
for me as an orthopedist the same thing
i might say i have a brace this is what
i need to have it do medically then they
go off to the brace maker and the brace
maker is the one that takes the
measurements of the limb
or the spine in my case the torso and is
then going to make that thing fit and if
it doesn't fit right it's their
responsibility to make it right that's
the person who's fitting
and if we interpose uh if if i as the
orthopedist gave these measurements and
they're not correct then i'm going to
lead him astray
so i think it's perfectly reasonable to
leave it this way
i mean there may be a person who goes in
and says hey you know i really want to
order it online would you just hold the
ruler up and measure it that's fine they
can do that if they want to but they're
not forced to do it it doesn't become
part of a spectacle
lens prescription
and the bottom line is there are some
things that just don't really work well
online if you order clothes online they
may not fit as well as if you've gone to
a tailor if you're going to order a
hearing aid online no way it may not fit
really well into your ear because i have
only a two millimeter canal on this side
and a bigger one on this side and that
was a real problem with fitting if i
tried to order it online it's not going
to work as well so this allows
it still allows that other stuff to
happen because there are ways to measure
it but i think this amendment is
perfectly fine i think the contact lens
piece doesn't need to be there because
the ftc is there but it does reinforce
it in our rule or sorry statute and
that's that's fine
so i'm very comfortable with this
anything else about representative
leon's amendment 867
now let's look at representative
merchants amendment 963
this
for myself was kind of a
tough one because of conflicting points
of view
ideally the patient should have the best
set of spectacles they can possibly have
unfortunately there's a lot of folks
that are on fixed incomes that cannot
afford a cadillac but could like a chevy
and the thing about a pupillary distance
being provided
it may not be accurate but for the vast
majority of patients talking to
authenticians it's probably okay
for those who need to have progressive
lenses or thick lenses precision becomes
important
so in listening to the testimony by the
optician and as a dispenser i can
understand what he's coming from
once you write something on a
prescription
as a dispenser you're bound to what on
is on that script
so therefore if we don't allow the
dispenser the authority to change and
modify the pd
we're locking them in and delaying
patient care or getting the spectacles
to the patient in a reasonable period of
time
so this allows the provider
to provide the pd if the patient request
it
and allows the dispenser to modify it to
make it precise versus accurate
so i think it was a good compromise all
the way around to allow for
the patients still have access to the pd
if they desire to do that if they're
shopping around and so forth aware of it
they can ask for at the time which is
written
and it also allows for the dispenser to
modify it if they need to
representative woods
thank you
i look at this from two perspectives and
appreciate the perspective that
represents merchant brought which is the
commercial track and thinking of this
particular problem in getting
the chevy
shall we speak instead of the cadillac
to the consumer and i appreciate that
i've been on the other end of the stick
myself
with my crazy eyes and trifocals um i
pay a pretty penny
nevertheless i'm looking at from the
medical perspective
what's going to happen in practice
is
the patient comes into the office and it
has to have a pd on it and well you may
need to have this changed and it can be
changed and so forth what's going to
happen it's going to go to
not every ophthalmologist i mean not
every optometrist or optician and not
every online facility but they're going
to take that as gospel truth
they're going well if we got one here
why should i measure it again
we've got 17 people in the waiting room
got to take care of them
so here's a pupillary distance you take
it uh and
on a
next customer
so
to
put it on the prescription
even though there is the
possibility okay of it once it's on a
and society takes the physician's
prescription
as gospel
for the most part
okay and i think that's where the
imprimatur of having that being the
primary
basis to proceed
although there some people will do fine
uh we also know that there are
prescriptions
that you can take a generic which don't
work as well
okay
uh and we we say
no not generic for that reason
and pharmacists are very familiar with
what's called a narrow therapeutic range
medication
typically uh thyroxine if you have a
thyroid disease
it has to be brand
because the generic for a vastness a
vast significant number
doesn't work uh so yes you can get the
generic
uh the chevy form but it's not going to
do the job
and i don't want to put the medical
community
in the position
of
pretending that this is really the best
care that i can provide for you
when it's really not
representative weber had her hand up
first
i'm not going to weigh in on either of
those issues but i'm i am going to say
that this
express a concern that this
makes significant changes in the contact
lens
portion as well as the spectacle portion
of the
statute
and i don't remember maybe somebody can
enlighten me that we had any testimony
at all about contact lenses or the
opportunity for anybody to know that
they might want to weigh in about
changes having to do with contact lenses
and once again i'm a little concerned
about
lack of germaness
i will say the other thing that i'm
concerned that i will just note is if
this is the directive we go in
on line 16 of the leon amendment there
is a comma after the word cylinder and
before the word access axis that i think
shouldn't be there
or representative uh canaric you want to
clarify yes actually because i quit i
was working with optometrists and i
questioned that when that came in that
original amendment
and it actually is sloppy wording period
all of it is
when you have a astigmatism you have not
a spherical error but a cylindrical
error
and so you actually have to have a
cylindrical refraction but then you have
to know the axis of that cylinder in
other words does it go straight up and
down or does it go across
and it really
probably should be saying the cylinder
refraction and the cylinder axis but
it's this is the length what the
language that was in there
was uh the optometrist said jargon and
what they would accept is just to say
the cylinder comma that means the
refractive power axis that means the
axis of it they were comfortable that
this would not be confusing we could
have made it all kinds of better talking
about for example they uh
the uh if you have a prism the prism
base orientation
strength all that stuff but you don't
need to put that in there they said it
was okay because what this is saying is
what you cannot change
so
it is that it does
is needed yeah it makes it better my
apologies that's okay i didn't know
either until i asked them so it's okay
the
the clerk pointed out to me that uh
contact lenses is in the original bill
so mention of it in an amendment may not
necessarily be non-germane i saw
here representative delemus you wish to
speak
yes thank you mr chairman um actually
i'm just going to chime in on
representative merchants amendment
and say that i really like it i think i
like it because the patient can request
the pupillary distance and
i did request pupillary distance from my
ophthalmologist when i went to get my
prescription which i actually have in my
pocketbook right now and that pupillary
distance box it was empty and as i said
before that i had to go sneak in to
the other side of the thing and had a
friend that actually does the the
measurements and did my eyes for me but
i if the doctor had just given me the
distance because i can't see if i take
these glasses off and i take a ruler and
i put the ruler up to my eyes and i'm
trying to see the distance between my
pupils i'm like i don't can't see a darn
thing so it's
i would trust a doctor it can actually
like maybe put a ruler up there and give
me the distance upon my request if i
don't
feel i need it or i don't want to get it
from
the doctor the prescriber then i don't
need to ask and and the reason that i
did ask was because i did buy these
online
thank you
representative gay
um i
i really like
the merchant
amendment because
there's two two types two categories of
people who would be interested
in um
not going to the
glasses dispensary that's at the
doctor's office
they are either
to order online
and we all understand that
that that's not ideal but that's
financially for people who who either
don't have the money to order it or
don't have lions to buy the glasses for
them
that's where they are they've got to
order it at something they can afford
they need that pupillary distance which
takes oh i don't know 10 seconds to make
of the other person who's going to go to
a cheaper place to make their glasses
they don't need it
and now they have gizmos that are so
quick
uh when i was waiting after my surgery
to get these
seven or eight hundred dollar glasses i
went and got some el chipos for a
hundred and they they you know these are
not highly trained people
uh and they measured measured me with a
cute little gadget
so i think it's really important to
guarantee that people have the right to
get that pupillary distance
because
not everybody can afford
what most of us can afford
and so i think it's very prejudicial to
say oh no you're not getting the
cadillac we need to make sure you do
representative weber
just as a matter of clarification to my
original point
yes fitting contact lenses was in the
original bill
but it was a replace all the the
language in the original bill is exactly
the same as the existing statute and we
didn't talk about contact lenses at all
it was i believe it was put in there as
a way of getting from section one to
section three which did have the
addition of the interpupillary distance
so i'm still i'm still concerned about
the contact lens section
um representative leon
thank you mr chairman um while i am
concerned about asking different
professions to cross train we can we can
measure our own intrapupillary distance
if we can see ourselves in the mirror so
i i do like the merchant amendment how
it can be modified and making it so that
it is more flexible
and if that's the way we ended up going
i'd be i'd be quite fine with that
are you withdrawing your amendment
um
or you're just happy i
there's different ways to skin a cat um
and it's hard to say that a professional
can't do what we can do with an app or a
ruler
um
i wouldn't skin a cat if i was a
professional but what would you like to
do with your amendment well i guess i
haven't submitted my amendment yet all
right we haven't we haven't made a
motion or anything we haven't
and what i'm asking is do you want us to
um
i see a hand over there i don't know
representative canark with respect to
the issue of the contact lenses although
it was not part of the original bill and
was not noticed as such we did have
testimony about the contact lenses
that's rosemary rungs amendment that she
brought in
and what
representative leon did was take her
amendment and blend it so it was covered
in testimony though it was not a notice
thing yeah so i think it's okay
okay germain wise i mean
representative gay
is there any reason we can't use adopt
both of these amendments
no yeah
oh because one says yes and one says no
about the pupillary distance
i will if it's okay i would
to make a motion on
amendment
2022-0963-h
which amended amends house bill 1-3
sorry 1-1-3-9
and you would like to make that motion
that it is ought to pass i bet right
motion to pass and then hopefully yeah i
bet it is
and wait a minute uh we're getting there
let's see we've got so many amendments
and
not as many as the constitution yet okay
so this merchant out
to p and who would like to second that
representative weber
okay speak some more
if you wish
why not i'll just call the vote
call the question
all right any objection anybody else
good thank you
the question before us is
amendment 2022-0963
to house bill 1139
moved by representative merchant
seconded by representative webber the
motion is ought to pass
and the clerk please call the roll
representative leon yes representative
mcmahon
representative acton yes representative
gay yes representative cushman yes
representative folsom yes representative
kelsey yes representative king yes
representative cole fault yes
representative delemus
representative weber
representative freitas yes
representative snow
representative knurk no
representative query
yes
representative cannon
yes representative nutter upham yes
representative shapiro
yes
representative woods no
representative
merchant yes representative pearson yes
19 19 to 22. now you're not going to
move
you're not okay so we moved to the bill
now
and we have before us house bill
1139 as amended
by 2022-0963
and i need i have nobody in my script so
this is a free for all who'd like to
move
this bill as amended we all know the
answer to that but i need to hear it
from himself
i knew it
a motion to
ought to pass with as amended
and somebody from over here
representative kelsey's
hand
reach to the sky
quicker than anyone else's
there's somebody over there who hasn't
gotten to second anything
i have a question
are we in the voting mode right now i i
was tr i was waving before the voting
mode but oh see i could wait till after
it was my interpupillary
problem here
would you like to say something well the
amen
may i you may the um we just passed the
amendment and it goes into effect
january 1st
2023 that's next year okay but the bill
goes into effect which we're probably
about to pass 60 days after passage
so
i wondered
who took precedence because i think
sooner's better than later
well
the amendment changes
the effective date okay thank you for
the answer
and this was to provide
an educational opportunity from the
various licensing boards to educate
their licensees about the requirement in
the statute and not springing upon them
within 60 days
would the clerk please call the roll on
house bill 1139 is amended by amendment
0963h moved by representative merchant
and seconded by representative kelsey
representative leon yes representative
mcmahon representative acton yes
representative gay yes representative
cushman
yes representative folsom yes
representative kelsey yes representative
king yes representative cofolt yes
representative delemus
representative weber
representative freitas yes
representative snow
representative knerk no
representative query
yes representative cannon yes
representative nutter uppam yes
representative shapiro yes
representative woods no
representative merchant yes
representative pearson yes 19 to 2
we've seen 19 to twos appear on
consent if there is no objection to
consent i see no objection to consent
well that means
representative merchant
in gratitude
all you've done
this amendment your cheery
demeanor
you get to write the blurb father thank
you
you know what the reward for good a job
well done is don't you
year do you want those blurbs
2023 when it's effective
and that
concludes the
exec session on 11 39 and i open the
exact session on
just make sure i have not been asked to
do this tomorrow i have not
house bill 1488 expanding the
prohibition against discrimination based
on an individual's
election not to participate in the state
vaccine registry
a bill of representatives
house bill 1488
and if you look at it it is remarkable
in its brevity
line two
no health care provider here's a change
or any other entity identified in
paragraph four well i looked it up
and a number of people are listed in
that paragraph four primary care
physicians nurses other appropriate
health care providers
schools child care agencies government
researchers
none of those therefore according to the
bill if passed shall discriminate
against any person solely
because that person elects not to
participate in the immunization registry
that's the bill
any discussion questions
representative woods uh just uh not that
people haven't read that it's
the registry not the vaccination and
other people have contacted me
with that misunderstanding so
this is just the non-participation in
the registry not the
non-participation in vaccination
and for the record 253
people signed in in favor of the bill
and 47 against
anyone else
looking for someone to
move the bill
i've got representative cushman in my
script to move the bill
um unless we have somebody on this side
of the playground who wants to
all right somebody's blurbed up
if not one gary how about another gary
one gary gary woods will do that now we
go over to this side of the playground
and representative acton
yes representative woods also known as
the blurb writer
any further discussion
for clarification i've been
notified that i said yes but i was not
clear what i said yes to
so but we thank you heartily yes
and you get to write the blurb which
means you move the question otp that's
correct is that good i yes i'll do my
best as i said
not being a writer in my physics
background the only thing i learned to
write were equations so i hope you'll
all be able to understand it
we just don't want to read the blurb and
think chaos
it will
the bill before us is house bill 1488
[Music]
moved by us on behalf of representative
woods
and seconded by representative acton
please with the clerk call the role
representative leon yes representative
mcmahon representative acton yes
representative gay
representative cushman yes
representative folsom yes representative
kelsey yes representative king yes
representative kobalt yes representative
delemus representative weber
representative oops i almost yeah rita
sorry
representative snow
representative knurk
yes representative querrey
yes
representative cannon yes representative
nutter upham yes representative shapiro
yes representative woods
yes representative merchant yes
representative pearson yes 21-0
gosh
is there any objection to this going on
to consent
seeing none it's on to consent and thank
you
representative woods for the blurb
i'll make my blurb short e equals m c
squared how's that
we want it positive and not relative
yes
and this
concludes the uh exec session on 1488
and i open the exec session now on
twelve
seventy
one
twelve seventy one
i don't do i see any amendments i do see
an amendment you have an amendment
oh we're going to itl all right
we don't have to study it
the chair calls on representative leon
for
a motion
thank you mr chairman i'd move interim
study on house bill 1271
and do we have second case
we do that was representative merchant
who's happy to speak if he doesn't have
to write another blurb okay wonderful
thank you
uh representative leon uh defend your
motion on interim study please um thank
you mr chairman i think that we had a
lot of good discussion around this
there are a lot of open issues around
that section that was added to law but
as we move out of this emergency
figuring out how to change it so that we
don't get rid of the protections that
were afforded and don't cause more
confusion by getting rid of this now
seems to be the best way to do this by
doing an interim study we can figure out
how to address these sorts of things
going forward and how
[Music]
basically how to address the concerns
that were raised in that hearing but
right now there's nothing that we really
need to do because that protection was
afforded during the covet crisis
and trying to figure out some way to
pull out that pull that out right now
just isn't the best way to go so interim
study is my preferred
path
any discussion no i just want to say
representative layout representative
merchant
i suck in your comments well said thank
you
wow
yeah
okay
seeing
silence hearing silence
the motion before us is interim study on
house bill 1270 one moved by
uh
who moved it you did okay my name was in
here that means i don't have to write
the bill now thank you god um removed by
representative leon and seconded by
representative merchant would the clerk
please call the role
representative leon yes representative
mcmahon representative acton yes
representative gay representative
cushman yes representative folsom yes
representative kelsey yes representative
king yes representative cofoult yes
representative delemus representative
weber
representative freitas yes
representative snow
representative knurk yes representative
querrey
yes representative cannon yes
representative nutter upham yes
representative shapiro
representative woods yes representative
merchant yes representative pearson yes
21-0
is there any objection to it going on to
consent i'm learning how to do this
without being prompted
seeing none it's on consent thank you
representative vice chair for the
forthcoming blurb
i make it we're up to 11
done is that what you have anybody keep
scores
you you have to write it down yes you do
wow maybe we have 12.
we have 12.
okay
that
the concludes session on 1271
and i now open the exec session on 14
95.
yeah we had voted on that one i think
before mr chairman
five
with an amendment coming your way
14.95 is with the government contractors
yep
everybody have one because i think i
have a two of them
they're coming
this is an extra one if anybody doesn't
have one
i mean it's an extra one even if they do
think about it
and on this bill as originally
proposed we have
435 people in favor
and 14
144 signed in against 435 to 144.
wow
uh yeah we can representative leon would
you speak to the amendment it really
shortens the bill
thank you mr chairman um this may seem
like a very large pivot from the bill
but almost all of those words are
included on page one lines three through
nine of the original bill
because this now prohibits the state of
new hampshire and its political
subdivisions from requiring businesses
to check this
the word customer was added as well so
that the state or any political
subdivision if things follow what we
have in this committee on the floor and
we keep the medical freedom and
immunizations the no it would not be
necessary but if the medical freedoms
and immunization
is removed which is a possibility on the
floor then this would be necessary
great answer
any other questions discussion
representative gay
is this a substitute or just for one
paragraph is this a yeah does this
replace the bill or look at line six
okay thanks representative weber
i'm just
needing a little bit of a clarification
it says the state's not going to require
any business to require a check for
possession of any documentation of
certifying vaccination or immunity
status
i know that the federal government
requires all airlines to check those
things
so
i'm just a little concerned about
this shouldn't didn't have any problem
with that because
that's federal as a state
i'm just wondering if there are any
circumstances
where this would be
inappropriate i i certainly agree it it
simplifies matters enormously
and it preserves the rights of
private businesses which i'm for it's
just it's a huge leap and i'm trying to
get my mind around it
representative leon would you
choose to answer please yes thank you mr
chairman and thank you for
for those uh question statements in
order to clarify this more
this simply says the state and its
political subdivisions can't require
that it does nothing to stop the federal
government from requiring it it does
nothing to stop cms from requiring it
all it says is that the state can't put
this mandate on businesses so the state
or its subdivisions cannot and follow-up
question follow-up yes um could you
remind me what rsa141c20a
is
yes that's childhood immunizations so a
childcare business a care facility
can still be required to check for that
immunization status okay so this is
kovitz specific
thank you very much representative snow
this also does not stop any business
from doing this on their own is that
correct
that is correct it just does not allow
does not make the state an agent to
force them to check for this they can do
what they choose
representative knurk uh i'd like to hear
from dhhs regarding
accreditation issues because
part of their accreditation is to check
that a facility
is following uh federal mandates and
granted this
this is still
a federal it's a federal but the state
is the one that actually accredits the
hospital
or the nursing home and makes sure that
they are following
the see the appropriate mandates that's
what they told us before so i would
assume either
perhaps paula minahan or john williams
could clarify for us will this interfere
with the ability for us to get
accreditation of our facilities
because they would not be able to do
their accreditation work because they
couldn't ask about whether or not
they're doing vaccinations to be
compliant with the federal mandates
they're consulting and one or both and
maybe even abby rogers for the hat trick
would come up and
enlighten us
first see the amendment from someone
please because i have not seen it
they're having a caucus
not a problem
use this time to think of the committee
amendments you're going to be writing
one of the three is at the table one
fled
and
ms rogers is in motion
oh good i did ice hockey play by play at
college
high members of the committee abby
rogers legislative liaison for the
division of public health services i'm
just going to take a second to review
the bill i believe that john williams is
reaching out to joe christie who's the
cfo of new hampshire hospital to get his
take on we didn't scare him off he'll be
back
so to answer
representative knurk's question um if
this prohibits the state of new
hampshire or its political subdivisions
re from requiring any business to check
or
to require a check for the possession of
any documentation for certified
vaccinations or immunization status
so the question really has to do with
the hospitals that are in the nursing
homes that fall under survey and
certification under the
department of hhs health facilities um
and the requirement will be for them to
ensure that the hospitals i'll just
speak for the hospitals but i think
nursing homes fall into this that the
department while they certify they have
to or go through the certification they
have to make sure that they're following
the cms policy so they will say show me
your policy
that requires you to ensure that
they
are vaccinated or have been given the
opportunity for an exemption
etc
and i believe you're right i believe
that any documentation will be how you
verify that
that they have in fact documented that
they're either
vaccinated or that they have um
received an exemption so i think
representative knurk
is correct the way i read it that this
could be in
conflict with that requirement of this
state
that does the
these certifications the cms
certifications
representative leon respond thank you mr
chairman
when i was looking at these with the
co-sponsors this doesn't prohibit them
from checking
whether they're compliant with other
requirements and other regulations it's
simply not allowing the state to be the
one telling them that they need to check
for
for those vaccinations and
documentations
we don't believe that it interferes with
their right to verify if they are in
fact following other requirements
representative canuck follow-up
but it says explicitly
that it shall not require
any of them to check
for the possession of any documentation
and that's precisely what accreditation
is all about is checking to be sure that
they have done that that is the job
that's why i brought that question up
and i think it does create a conflict in
the statute
representative merchant
i
i hear what you're saying represent
i read it somewhat differently because
the way i see this
is they're not requiring
the documentation based upon a state
request or state requirement they're
doing it based upon a federal
requirement
so therefore when i read through this
the political subdivisions shall not
require any business or
to inquire or check on the possessions
of our documentation but that's at the
state level versus trying to be sure
that the complying with the federal
level
representative canarch but it is the
state level at which accreditation is
carried out and that is the problem
because that is what they do they go in
and they say
show us your
um
policies show us these things that is
how we accredit you so they're not
actually helping the federal government
with compliance at all they're simply
accrediting the institution and credit
to accredit the institution
they must check
that documentation
and that's and they're not checking it
as a federal requirement they're
checking it as a state requirement for
licensing that is a state requirement
and that's why that's happening that's
why there's a conflict representative
cushman
you mr chairman um i i'm in agreement
with representative merchant uh the way
that i read this is that it just can't
be a dictate coming from the state this
business needs to require or check
status
of
of anyone
and that the businesses if they want to
comply with federal regulations
and they're seeking certification
they can do that
but the state can't tell them
that that's what they need to do
representative kenner you're on a roll
this is my last what
but i regardless what you think it means
or the other sponsors think it means i
think we really ought to listen to the
people who actually are doing the
accreditation and how they would
interpret it and that's why i brought
this question up
um and so i think that we still have a
i'm not i know you weren't trying to
make a difficulty but i think it does
that's my concern
anything at this point that represents
uh yeah sorry
ms rogers uh ms linahan manhattan wish
to say at this point sure i would say
that uh i represent public health
services so technically accreditation is
not under my purview for the department
necessarily but i can say i do agree
with representative kenner that it does
seem to propose
a little bit of a conflict with that
with the certification having to ask
business or employees have said business
especially if they're a healthcare
business whether
there is a vaccination status
in place if that's required to do their
business and required by licensure okay
representative folsom
thank you um
there's nothing in this that says a
business
can't require that
it just says the state can't require it
so if you're a hospital or a nursing
home
and you know that cms would like you to
do this
if you want your money
then they choose as the hospital yes
we're gonna we are going to require that
of our employees because
that's what cms is requesting so it's
not the state telling the hospital and
nursing home you have to do that it's a
decision made by the hospital to follow
the cms guidelines
except the state and that's probably not
the right term but they are kind of
agents of cms when it comes to survey
and certification they contract with cms
to survey the nursing homes and survey
the critical access hospitals we're not
talking about all our hospitals we're
talking about the critical access
hospitals because they use the um health
facilities licensing cms certification
it it is a cms certification so that is
that's the same concern that i have with
1455 that got passed as is um
um
the speaker's bill it
that was our testimony in that bill and
i think it's still flawed because it it
is going to be a problem um there's
going to be a conflict and i think the
agency is going to be con have a trouble
um unless it's clarified in here that
nothing in this um chat in this
paragraph um you know and i
i probably could come up with some
language but nothing in this paragraph
would prohibit um
that
from occurring because again they i
don't know if agent is the right term
i'm looking at um representative weber
maybe it is the right maybe that is the
right term um but it's they are acting
on behalf of cms they have a contract so
that's why it it it causes a conflict it
does i think it does representative
weber
i haven't seen the documentation but it
sounds to me like it's an agency
relationship and
i was when i when i first started
thinking about this i was wondering if
there was a way to
say
well i was instantly thinking new
hampshire hospital in the county nursing
homes and i
thought well maybe if we just insert the
word private business here
that would take care of it but it
doesn't because some of the hospitals
are not state-run hospitals
so
i don't know
whether you fix it by putting the
disclaimer that you're talking about in
so that
those evaluations can continue to take
place
or whether you carve out
hospitals nursing homes and medical
facilities which probably doesn't
fulfill
the intent of the people who proposed it
i mean i
i'm trying to figure out a way
of
having it apply to all those businesses
i mean i love the idea that the business
is given the right to decide what
they're going to collect and people can
work there people can work somewhere
else and that's that's all good
or people can attend or not attend
um
i was
wondering if
and now i've sort of lost the thought
but
i i was thinking of a carve out
but i'm increasing
the thing i'm wondering about is are
there other businesses
that might be in the same
state
that might might need the same kind of
carve outs and i can't think what they
are because
i'm here on the health and human
services committee and and the hospitals
and the nursing homes are what come to
my mind
so contractors
federal contractors possibly um
yeah i feel like we're at a disadvantage
because we're just seeing this amendment
right now um and i i i need to think
this through a little bit more of the
unintended consequences representative
webber continue um
i think
i think i i was kind of persuaded by
representative leon that if the
if the mandate comes solely from the
federal government straight down onto
whoever it's falling on
that that comes from the federal
government and this doesn't
cover it i think the time we get into
squishy
territory
is
this specific instance where
because of the contract with the federal
government the state is the enforcer
of
requirements that come from the federal
government so i think the state is in in
many ways mandating it even though it
was originally the federal government
that did it so
whether it's a carve out or or whether
it's clarifying language i think i would
be a lot more comp
a lot more comfortable if we went that
direction mr williams do you have news
from the front
chairman pearson members committee
regrettably um i usually come through
but i could not get a hold of either mr
joe christie that testified before this
committee on the underlying bill from
new hampshire hospital or nathan white
who is our director for our procurement
unit
i can try to get information to this
committee on whether or not there are
any issues to the bill we do appreciate
the work that was done by the committee
i think to try to address the concerns
i just can't independently without
confirming with either one of those two
gentlemen that this doesn't present any
problems for the department um i did
earnestly get try to get a hold of them
uh one is out of the office today and
tomorrow and the other one i will
definitely continue to track down
you know where he lives i do okay that's
all i'm asking
thank you
representative gay
how about where it says it's um in line
14 where it says accept as specified in
rsa141c
i didn't look up 141c but
because it's already giving an exception
how about except we're required by
federal law
you are addressing that to whom
everybody
anybody representative cushman thank you
mr chairman uh just a couple of points
so we've i've heard i've gotten
testimony from the president of the
american association of certifying
agencies that are is a
uh basically like a union a professional
organization that represents all of the
medicare medicaid cms certifying
agencies across the country and in the
states where they are
they have bills similar to 1455 that we
just passed in 1604 where they will not
be certifying based on certain
requirements such as the vaccine mandate
that they've just continued to certify
and
it's
you know there have been no negative
consequences from that i also don't see
why our state
agencies couldn't just say
the state isn't legally allowed to
require this but if you want to meet the
federal requirement you need to provide
this kind of
policy have a question for the amendment
principal amendment writer
um
would it be your pleasure to try to keep
what we have and vote it however we will
or would you like to bring in something
tomorrow as a another amendment
thank you very much for that i think
that
let's see
let's um we'll consider it overnight and
either bring this back up or bring
another amendment tomorrow so what
you're suggesting is we should now move
towards recessing this and not come to a
decision representative
just one last comment while we're
thinking about this question though
i think it's important to remember that
we've had a lot of bills that came in
based upon covet 19
but the changes they make are sweeping
and
for the future
one of the big problems is ever trying
to legislate
public health responses because they
need to be nimble and fast and
legislative processes intentionally
rather slow
to remember this doesn't say anything
about covert 19 this would be anything
so if we got some other kind of
incredibly horrendous
pandemic of some sort respiratory as the
usual type of
thing we have to think of um
this would not allow our public health
agencies to
have the flexibility that they might
want not that they would if we think
about it
in this which was a you know the biggest
one for our lifetimes in a century
the state was not mandating
the businesses
through vaccinations i very much doubt
they ever would but i'm not sure we
should be prohibiting and tying the
hands of our public health people
for a
highly unlikely situation but if a
highly unlikely situation comes we don't
want them to say sorry we can't do
anything about this so i was still
leaning toward just simply
itl on the bill
rather than trying to parse this to
become a little less troubling because i
don't think we actually need it anyway
representative leon thank you mr
chairman while i appreciate that
there's a question of what's around the
corner
back before i was a representative i
came and testified at one of the
emergency powers hearings in that one
they were talking about any excess
supplies the way it was written
food beyond that day your child's
medication beyond that day could have
been confiscated
three bicycles with two people in the
household that that third bicycle could
be confiscated so it's our job to make
sure that the response is in keeping
with the demands and that we do have
reasonable limits that that our agencies
will work around
i'm convinced that in an ebola pandemic
or anything like that the businesses
themselves would be requiring this out
of protection and in something that is
far more virulent than covid19 i don't
think we need the state to act in order
to get people to follow through but i
just instead of moving forward on this
let's recess it and try and get through
a few more bills
thank you
all right the chair accepts that
suggestion and we are going to recess on
1495 but we will be looking at it
tomorrow
i opened the executive session on
1409 relative to the age at which a
minor may receive mental health
treatment without
parental consent
and you may remember yes
an amendment
we have an amendment is that 513
amendment
but he also wants to make an
announcement and representative shapiro
i can't hear you sir
thank you this is not specifically about
this bill but since we've had so many
bills that involve
um consent and confidentiality for
adolescents in terms of
vaccines and this one in terms of mental
health center i came across
an adolescent and young adult health
care in new hampshire a guide to
understanding consent and
confidentiality laws
done by a national organization so i've
made copies that not enough copies for
everybody but i'll leave the copies
by representative folsom and if anybody
wants one
feel free to take it thank you very much
coming around is representative weber's
amendment zero five one three
and when we've all had a chance to look
at it
we'll ask you to
walk us through it
i have one
and on 1409
people signed in in favor of the bill
and 152
signed in
against this bill 1409.
do we have more 1409s
amendments coming around
anybody have a spare amendment
did i get one
i don't know
she'll make them she's gonna make a few
boy i'm gonna miss having a photocopier
next door
does everyone now have a copy of
amendment 0513
it's a quick read
and would representative
um explain her amendment
thank you very much you remember that
when
house bill 1409 came to us it had long
and complicated provisions on
how um
treatment was going to be paid for and
whether what insurance was going to
cover and there were terrible unresolved
questions with how
one maintained confidentiality with a
minor when their
parents were going to be
presented with an explanation of
benefits so
this dodges frankly all of those
questions by simply stating
and as representative shapiro can speak
more about
the state of stuff as it is right now
but but it's a little unclear so all
this does
is it says that a minor who is 16 or
older
may voluntarily consent to mental health
services
so that's the minor may consent
and a licensed mental health care
provider may provide the services
without the consent of the parent or
guardian
provided that they're not going to
provide medication
so
for
the kids who cannot go to their parents
because their
relationship with their parents
is not such
that their parents
are already helping them look after
their mental health
which is of course what we want for
every child
it allows a kid who
needs help
is 16
to go and get that help
and it balances the interests you know
we heard a lot of
concern
when we had the hearing of you know my
kid may be taking a medication that i
know nothing about and
heard that concern so we limited it
strictly speaking to
talk therapy so it clarifies that the
kid may and that the practitioner man
doesn't go any further than that so
with that i would be glad to offer
amendment
and the committee can do with it as they
please
representative folsom
thank you um
just a question of some wording that
kind of throws it in two different
directions you just spoke of a person
a minor 16 or older could seek out help
but the way it's written here
is they're not seeking it
they're consenting to somebody else who
has decided they needed counseling
consent is a legal term of art which is
used generally speaking for
uh
who may agree to services either
you know if i go to the hospital i have
to consent for them
to treat me
if a kid goes to the hospital generally
speaking the parent or guardian consents
on behalf of the kid so this is not
implying that somebody's coming up to
somebody and going hey kid you want to
have some mental health counseling in
the back alley this is actually the
legal term
that we usually speak of
for
somebody
approaching
a mental health counselor and you you
you either agree that yes it's a good
thing for 16 year olds to be able to do
this or you don't and i know that there
are many varied opinions on that but
um
i think the drafting probably should be
okay
i spoke with the
prime sponsor of the bill
and it is her assertion
that she eventually
incrementally
would like to move the age to 12.
in fact a bill that she previously filed
i believe had that age in it
and i would also say that
there are many steps
that were not mentioned
between
going to one's parent or not
and going to a mental health counselor
so many kids who just want to talk out
something
go to a member of the clergy
a coach a teacher
a friend
a whole variety of people who may not be
licensed mental health counselors but
people who need to talk things out can
go to them
however i think when we get to the level
of the mental health counselor the
professional
licensed trained
people who then
[Music]
would want to go to such professionals
i would think don't just have a little
thing they want to talk through they got
a big problem
and i have to look at that big problem
in that why they cannot talk with their
parents may speak of something that is
systemic within that family that may
warrant further intervention
what this does is short-circuit it
it
keeps secrets until they're exposed and
then oh my gosh secrets have been told
to others
i
see this as the erosion not the helping
of the family system being fully well
aware of some pretty bad families
anyone else
representative snow
thank you mr chairman i i do think the
other issue is
a kid whether it's 12 or 16 i hope it
doesn't go back to 12 because that to me
is a big problem
but if it is 16 16 year olds are
ordinarily under the family's
health insurance policy
if they're going to go to a professional
counselor they're going to have to
request
that they're going to have to give the
information about their insurance and
the parents will be getting
the
information that it's being paid and i
don't know if medicaid some of them are
going to be covered through the medicaid
system
i'm assuming that the youngster can do
it but whether or not that requires the
parents
to request that it come under their
medicaid coverage i think remains to be
seen
but it is it is kind of a complicated
issue within it
i do remember talking with the
representative who sponsored this bill
and raised questions about whether this
can be any way tied in
to the emancipation of minor bills which
are in that's a court proceeding where
essentially
the child essentially divorces his
parents and can make adult decisions on
his own
but again it leaves open the problem of
how does he cover the cost of this
policy and so far none of that's been
i think the assumption is you can go i
could agree to see him but i have to
understand i might not be getting paid
for what i'm going to be doing
exactly
representative shapiro
yes i think this bill is very limited in
scope purposely um because those other
issues like payment are so complicated
um i would say that
as in most of the bills that we have
we have competing benefits and
consequences on both sides
and
while i don't tend to use the term
parental rights
because i think
are also parental responsibilities and
um it's not like
parental rights to me implies like
ownership of our kids a little bit and
um i don't think that's what people mean
when they use the term but i do agree
with um
mr chairman with your
thoughts about wanting to this is the
kids family and as much as we can
help the family work out problems this
is for the best
however i think on the other hand
the competing benefits and consequences
are that
there are some
young adults adolescents who do not have
parents who for various reasons are
able to provide the proper guidance and
support and help
and this would
this would allow those
kids
those six 16 and 17 year olds
um not easily
because this bill doesn't make it easy
but potentially to
access mental health care and i i have a
i have a list that was handed out during
testimony i would say that half the
states
about 25 out of the 50 states in the
united states
um
allow for
adolescents to access
mental health care without
their parents consent some as young as
12 but many are 16 some are 14. it's all
over the place but this is not an
uncommon
phenomenon
i would just ask the representative um
i've done some a fair bit of counseling
in my capacity you've done it as a
professional licensed counselor do you
see that most kids are bereft
of having
a coach a teacher
the guy at the drop or gal at the
drop-in center
that
people can go to if the parents are not
the ones
well what i would say is that
one of the main
factors in how
how kids do
is whether they have a they often use
the term charismatic but
you know a caring
and concerned
and someone who's willing an adult
that's willing to come forward even if
they they don't have the family supports
that having an adult
who is um
available to them really available to
them
is one of the main factors in how kids
do as they come into adulthood and i
think this just
you know some adolescents have those
other people they have a coach they have
a somebody at the boys and girls club
however it's kids from families who are
having a lot of problems
who tend to
participate less in those activities
church um religion
um so i think i'd i would not
i would not say that those other adults
are
unimportant i would just say that this
adds another
um resource for
16 and 17 year old adults to get help
when they're hurting representative
knurk
uh yes and i would agree i think that's
the issue is that it'd be a rather small
number of kids who would actually
do this
it would be that rare child who does not
have anybody that they can turn to and
it's also important to realize that some
of the
a coach may be great to teach you how to
handle a soccer ball but they may not be
the best person to talk to if you are
being
sexually abused by your
stepbrother
that just may not be an optimal person
to go to to have that conversation
now the thing is that
the issue yes we cut out all the
reimbursement that can be a problem but
charity care has been provided by
providers
for
hundreds of years
and i think if you had a provider who
had a child come in that was really in
trouble and sought care
they probably i think a fair number of
them would be willing to treat
a small number of those kids for a short
time if necessary and then try to engage
the family i think just about every good
provider would try to engage the family
ultimately
um and there's another point i was going
to make but i forgot now what it was
representative shapiro will buy you some
time
i also want to point out that this is
you know potentially an added resource
for
teens
and a protection for teens
but it's also a protection for
clinicians who want to provide this care
i think the landscape now is incredibly
unclear about what the age of consent
actually is
and
this would just make it clear that if
if those mental health clinicians
chose to
that they would have some protection in
working with
an older adolescent
representative snow
yes i
want to
remind people i believe most of you may
have been present whether or not it was
this year or during the last session
that we had some very meaningful
testimony by a young woman who at the
time was a student at unh
but during her last two years of high
school she was very depressed
considered suicide from time to time
and her parents because of being
embarrassed
by having a child with
mental problems refused to allow her to
have any contact with a mental health
professional until she got to unh where
she did have access to the gun do you
remember hearing that testimony and
i think when it gets to the point
that woman sounded like she was the kind
of trouble that a coach or a friend is
really not going to be a great deal of
help for
and certainly i worked in the business
for a long time i think if a child that
young i take the risk of trying to see
them and i think most people would but i
agree with him that this bill if it
passes would
tend to clarify that a little bit but i
think most people if they thought
they were going to be able to prevent a
suicide now
one of the things that often happens
when you see them is you usually want to
start them on some sort of medication
and at that point i do agree with her
that
we would have to involve the family at
that point i think that would be
irresponsible but leading up to that
point maybe
if you at least make that first gesture
of sitting down and seeing them
understanding the problem making sure
that they know that you as the counselor
are on their side and want to help
that they may be able to listen to you
about taking other steps that might
improve that degree of health
so i don't know if i'm making any sense
but i do think this is a very serious
issue and it
we do have to think about
kids i'm still opposed to lowering the
age much below 16 but i would be
comfortable with this
under those circumstances
and
i think we have to use common sense some
things are just very serious and we got
to take them seriously representative
kanark have you rediscovered your second
point
i figured out why it left my head it
went sucking right down to
representative snow because that was
precisely what i was going to do is
harken back to that desperate woman who
was unable to get help when she was
under 18. thank you for doing that
representative snow
representative merchant
thank you mr chairman
this also allows i think
for a school psychologist
to
speak to a minor
who probably needs some therapy
for whatever reason
and i think again back to the same thing
we're not trying to destroy the family
we're actually trying to repair it
the pair the students here i i can share
with you
from my wife was a school nurse
there are many
times in which a child needs help
but the parent is the barrier to it so
i don't think this bill is trying to
destroy the family unit i really think
it's trying to repair the family unit as
that has been destroyed in allowing
health care professionals the
opportunity
to talk to a child at that age
to try to help them understand that the
parents really aren't that bad they're
just trying to look at life differently
and try to find a way to bridge the gap
between the minor and the parent is
going to be critical
representative cushman
thank you mr chairman
i have to um
acknowledge that you know there are
some cases where parents do not
provide what is needed for a child
but again we
circle back to the issue of
taking away the rights of some
because of a few bad actors
and
i have concerns about a minor
16 years
17 years old
being alone in a room with someone
without their parents knowledge
i think it puts them in and that person
in a dangerous situation when the
parents are left out of that
representative gay
thank you i discussed this with my
daughter
who is the
parent of two
older teens
and she immediately said but mom
there's too many kids who don't have
responsible parents
and so
you know i i feel
torn in both these directions
but i don't think i would have had to
fear
if my child went to the counselor and i
know in my in salem
i'm told that it's
the kids the counselors have the right
the fact that the child's in school they
have the right to see the counselor
there they don't need a written pass
from the parents
but i also know
that the counselors
are way overworked
and have way too many kids
and if you listen to judge broderick a
lot of kids come to him every time he
goes and speaks at a school
wherever
tons of kids come and tell him that they
are so troubled
so
i'm going to fall off the fence on that
on the side that i would rather
that they see a counselor
and you certainly hope that the
counselor is responsible and does
everything they can
to do the family repair
that's needed
representative weber
may i make a motion the chair is going
to make a motion
okay the chair makes the motion
inexpedient to legislate
seconded by representative kelsey
may i make an inquiry of the chair you
may
so the motion is inexpedient to
legislate so if i want to pass the bill
with the amendment i need to vote
against the itl and then bring a motion
on the amendment is this correct thank
you sir
representative shapiro
yes before we vote i would just like to
say that
i know
that some people are going to view this
as
taking away something from parents
and i would um
i would just ask people to understand
that
people who have an engaged
positive
maybe not 100 positive but an engaged
relationship with their adolescent
children
um
there's going to be discussion with
their adolescent children before they go
to therapy it's this is not gonna this
is not gonna create a um wave of people
running away from their parents to um
secretively
secure therapy people who have
um
positive healthy relationships with
their
kids this will be discussed and probably
the parents will go with them to therapy
the first time and introduce them to the
therapist or there'll be a family
systems and
perhaps there'll be a family systems
person who works with the whole family
which is a very good thing um so
i hope people will not view this as only
taking something away or taking rights
away from parents but offering
um
a resource for some kids for whom this
might be a lifesaver thank you
representative kanark
mine's more a parliamentary inquiry on
most of the bills today
if an amendment was offered we took up
that amendment first and voted before we
then voted on the bill and here we're
going straight to itl i know we could do
that but
would we would it be kind to go ahead
and consider the amendment first and
then move on to the bill
i have been overruled by
my ranking member
thank you
anyone else wish to speak
once again i would reiterate the fact
that there's a lot of steps between
talking with one's parents
and needing to engage a professional
licensed credentialed mental health
expert
many people do have a coach and some
coaches coach soccer and not kids
but there are other coaches or teachers
or clergy or boys and girls club people
and if it gets to the place where
they're just not
able to do it because the problem is so
great
then we do have a great situation in
that family
and to keep the parents out of that loop
at that point may well make it worse
so
i do not see this as being of help
a parliamentary inquiry you may
so if somebody wants to ultimately
vote for the amendment
right now because the itl motion is
before us we should vote down the itl so
we can get to the amendment this is
correct thank you
further parliamentary information
has there been a second
there has been
yes there has been and whose second
representative kelsey has a second did
this
okay
the motion before us on house bill
1409 is an expedient to legislate moved
by the chair seconded by representative
kelsey
the clerk may call the role please
representative leon yes representative
mcmahon
representative acton yes representative
gay
representative cushman yes
representative folsom yes representative
kelsey yes representative king yes
representative cofoult yes
representative delemus
representative weber
no
representative freitas no
representative snow no representative
knurk no representative query
representative cannon
representative nutter upham no
representative shapiro no representative
woods
no
representative merchant
representative pearson yes
10 to 11 10 11 the motion fails the
chair recognizes representative weber
for a motion thank you mr chairman i
would move amendment 0513
and do we have a second
representative nada upham
any discussion
saying none the motion before us is on
amendment zero five one three ought to
pass moved by representative weber
seconded by representative nutter upham
would the clerk please call
thank you
representative leon
representative mcmahon
representative acton
representative gay
representative cushman
representative folsom no representative
kelsey
representative king
representative cofoult
representative delemus
representative weber yes representative
freitas yes
representative snow yes representative
knurk
representative querrey
representative cannon
representative nutter upham yes
representative shapiro
representative woods yes representative
merchant
yes
representative pearson no
11 to 10
amendment carries 11 to 10 the clerk
recognizes representative weber for a
further motion
thank you mr chairman uh i would move
out to pass as amended by amendment zero
five one three on house bill
1409. and do we have a second
representative nutter upham
any further discussion
the motion before us is on house bill
1409 as amended by
2022-0513 the motion is ought to pass as
amended
moved by representative weber seconded
by representative nutter upham
the clerk may call the roll
representative leon no representative
mcmahon
representative acton no representative
gay
representative cushman no
representative folsom no representative
kelsey no representative king
no
representative kobalt
no representative delemus
representative weber
yes representative freitas yes
representative snow yes representative
knurk yes representative query
yes representative cannon yes
representative nutter upham yes
representative shapiro yes
representative woods
representative merchant yes
representative pearson no
11 to 10 emotion the motion carries
ought to pass is amended carries 11 to
10.
and would you like to write the
committee report
i didn't catch who seconded the
amendment uh
representative nada up oh
and the bill and the bill oh okay that's
why i was confused okay thanks
uh minority report me
do people need a break or you want to
keep going
oh yes do you want to have a break or do
you want to keep going yes
they're voting for break
okay let's take about a ten minute break
really surprised
it's not always about abused kids you
know i know the really smart kids whose
parents demand they become doctors and
their poets
you know 16 trying to fight out what
college to go to and whatever i mean
there's lots of reasons kids go to
therapy
well i still think that kid
i remember how impressed i was with her
did she testify oh yeah yeah yeah i mean
she was so desperate my parents never
went
it was a snobby thing it wasn't even
anything
they just were embarrassed
well of course i wouldn't know where to
find a therapist but my parents wouldn't
let me it's not going to happen all that
often and i don't think we would have
gotten to that and i think one of the
things that hurts us is just one
original sponsor
well i hope she doesn't run again i
think
young black man that testified and
whatever you know she's just
and then she made
something on facebook you probably
learned on facebook she goes how about
christians give up hating jews for less
i'm like
yeah don't take
i had the same experience she came to me
way back when she had that first bill
with that
yeah
i didn't want to sound too negative all
right so i said well
you know let's think about this
maybe if you made this bill a little
more
comparable
it took a little older age she just
unfortunately
you know well you know i worked at a
mental health center we're mandated to
see people oh yeah i wasn't i was trying
to turn a profit which i didn't but
well and that that is a big problem
so like
i had this one woman came in
her brother or brother-in-law got
deported
the sister-in-law was in prison
and or the other way around whatever
yeah their sister-in-law was in france
so she took in their child or two
children and she had three of her own
and she's working a full-time job at
sears
and so she has insurance so i call the
insurance and i see so how many visits
does she have and they said oh unlimited
after she makes her acceptable
and i'm like what's her deductible seven
thousand dollars
this is july and she's made 1500 bucks
sounds reasonable to me
i'm kidding you're terrible
anyway so i saw her
yep i am a quick i saw her for free for
a bunch of times you know i mean like
she's
losing well anyway
if i don't go to the men's room i'm
going to be in serious trouble
oh
what
i have glad tidings
so any trumpets
thank you
we are garling this
the shapiro
vacation
and it will run from march 21 to 25.
in that there will yes
in that there is no thing in the big
building with the gold dome
and there will be no
meetings of this committee
you get the week off
i would like to give credit to
representative leon who first suggested
um that week to me
we will in the spirit of bipartisanship
call it the shapiro leon or
the other amendment is the leon shapiro
vacation week
21 to 25 of this very month
representative canark may come in to
work if he wishes no no no just a
question though too
next week we have potential house
sessions wednesday thursday are you
intending for us to have any committee
work next week or once we finish this
are we done uh because we're waiting for
the senate bills
i've changed my uh mail address to an
unlisted number and therefore
no crossover bills have come my way i
don't know if anyone out there listening
knows of any but they have not been
given to me
so
long and short are we or we are not
meeting on march 14 and 15.
no committee meetings that's what i mean
okay so we are not meeting as a
committee on march 14 or 15 nor are we
meeting on 21 or 22 rights
yes we have house session days yeah
that's what i said yeah see this is the
sim this is similar to a state
mandate versus a federal member no no i
i knew we were not having the week off i
was asking about our committee and then
what about the
march 28 and 29 for our committee
we'll see
got it okay so just take the win and
shut your mic off thank you got it
no i'm not worried about a win just want
to know
okay the last time march 21 to 25 we now
i now open the um exec session on house
bill
relative
to the procedure for withdrawing
from the vaccine registry there is a
merchant amendment
983 of which i have a whole big stack of
and i'm very happy to share
they're coming they're coming coming
okay
okay you should have had a chance to
read 1487 and the chair calls on
representative merchant
to
explain the amendment
side by side with the bill
thank you mr chair
in regards to the
language if you go back to the original
bill
under four
this is unoriginal bill not the
amendment under four
the way it words is
different than the amendment and that's
going to be on the line where it says
the general court finds a requirement
for current and former health care
provider to sign the form i change it to
read
differently
finds that limiting the requirement to a
current and health care provider which
is what we're talking about we're
limiting the option for the patient on
the bill itself
you're looking at line 12.
on on the amendment you're looking at
line five
and where changes between the words
finds that the
requirement which is on line 12 of the
bill
was changed in line five the court finds
that limiting the requirement
so it inserted a word a single word why
because
it's
limiting the requirement if we're going
to basically at that point in time allow
for the options for the patient to opt
out
we need to change it to
something that's more broad
and saying limiting so it's
what happened was the way the original
bill was written the legislative intent
was talking about the requirement
for a current health care provider
versus limiting it only to them
okay it's it's a
it's in my opinion it was more of a
grammatical change
the other part though was
on
the
bill itself
if you go to line 19
in line 20.
what it talks about is a healthcare
provider either current or former and
what came up during the conversation was
not to limit that
was to allow for the patient to sign the
form without the
signature of a current health care
provider the challenge there is that if
we only allow the patient to do it
the department health and human services
will not know if the signature was
actually that of the patient which is
fraud
versus that coming from the patient
themselves
so what we talked about what i came up
with was
if you go back to the amendment on the
beginning of line four end of line 14
the form shall be signed by a current or
former health care provider or the form
shall be notarized by an official
authorized by a government governmental
authority to notarize the signature
to prevent the issue of fraud because
that was one of the things that was
raised and discussed was how do i know
that the signature on that form is in
fact that of the patients that's why we
wanted the provider to
sign the form because if they're signing
it they know the patient signed it so to
avoid the issue of fraud by having a
notarize which a patient can do you can
simply bring it down to a notary and
have it signed in front of the notary
and submit the form
any questions or comments on this
representative leon thank you mr
chairman
thank you for this amendment and looking
at these different options i'm looking
at the words in the last line or the
form shall be notarized by an official
authorized by a governmental authority
to notarize the signature
is that the way that we normally refer
to notaries because that seems really
confusing to me well it's the way i
wrote it at ten o'clock last night
without a migraine yeah without a
migraine so
i i think it's a little bit more um
complicated the way i written it but i
think the intent is pretty clear that
has to be notarized
and i wanted to be sure that someone
this is back not knowing the issue about
notre notarizing a form that the
signature is being notarized not the
form
right representative weber
i was going to just say that i think it
may be more words than are necessary but
i think it conveys the meaning that we
just want
some verification that the person
signing the form is not
your ex-spouse who's angry at you and
has decided to remove all records that
you yourself want to keep
and it's a relatively easy way of doing
it and gets around the problem of those
people who don't have their health care
provider here
you know or have their health care in
vermont or maine or whatever it is i
think it's a great
way of preserving the original intent
while making sure that their fraud is a
little less easy
you just couldn't bring yourself to
write notary republican could you
represent
representative connerk
thank you i once again would like to
just check in with the department about
something
on line 13 in the amendment um and this
was actually in the original bill to
request the removal of information from
the registry we heard when we had the
previous bill about
removal of covert 19 vaccine information
which came in under the emergency
authorization
that this was the only medical record
and those records needed to be retained
normally medical records need to be
retained for seven years
in this case since the provider will
have actually given the vaccination is
it a fair assumption that the medical
record will still be
preserved
because the medical record resides in
the provider's office
or will this cause any problem with
removing information likewise i guess i
would have to say if this would apply to
the coveted 19 where there is no other
record will this be a problem could the
department clarify that for us
would the department like to clarify
that
and here they come
three of the 2800 people who work at the
department
or two
two
good afternoon committee members and
commissioner pearson thank you very much
ann marie mccary from the department of
health and human services immunization
section chief
that is correct we would be in conflict
where if the new hampshire state of
the state of new hampshire was the
provider for coving 19 vaccination
deleting these
records would mean that we would be
deleting the only record on file
and therefore we would be in conflict
with maintaining that medical record for
seven years
follow-up follow-up may i ask then can
you think of a way to
make this
workable um
would it just be a matter of saying that
it requests remove information from
after seven years or i mean how do we
make this actually work so that it
doesn't create a conflict but still
provides what representative merchant is
trying to do
i believe that we could handle the forms
in a similar way to how we handle the
opt-out forms those paper records are
kept out of the ias it's a separate
system they are paper records that are
stored in a hipaa compliant area
so follow up again follow up so in other
words you could live with this because
you would remove them from the registry
but you would keep the records we would
just have to make sure perhaps that
would be something that we'd want to
make sure that the population with the
public would be aware of that when this
occurs
information would still reside there so
they would not all information
disappears but the information in the
registry would disappear
is that correct that would be correct
thank you for your question
representative merchant
thank you for that
um i want to be clear though the forum
we're talking about it currently is in
existence
all we're doing at this point in time is
allowing
not just only the provider to sign it
but a patient to sign as long as it's
been authorized so therefore we're still
utilizing the form the issue we're
talking about still exists
yes that is true
representative woods
uh thank you so just to clarify in other
words that could be handled in rules
with this
being removed
i'm sorry i can't hear you sir
i think he's just trying to clarify so
this is currently done in rules to hold
the paper record so it's already being
done so it's not an issue that is
correct
representative gay
thank you
i guess i'm kind of puzzled if we're
trying to
remove
a record
from the registry
how is that removal if you're retaining
the record
thank you very much for your question
the ias is a specific system the
immunization registry that is built to
consolidate immunization records so that
providers in many different areas could
go ahead and access that if we are
removing that record from that database
that system that record would no longer
exist in that system a paper record
would not be in a form that could be
shared in any way shape or form it would
be
basically stored in the event that we
needed to retrieve that
follow-up
it still sounds
who could access it i'm i'm
not thinking i'm thinking
i'm pushing the envelope to the ultimate
so i'm not thinking a real incident but
if somebody really didn't want their
records held anywhere
could they
opt that there's no paper record or you
give the paper record to
to the person who got the immunization
so they could it was their
responsibility to keep it
medical providers are required by law to
retain a record for seven years so just
like you would not be able to ask your
doctor to delete your record
that record has to be retained that's a
requirement
we would just do it separately outside
of the ias so that we would have that
record on file to maintain that
compliance with maintaining for seven
years
representative weber
and just to further beat the dead horse
the purpose of all of this is that
information in the registry can be
shared under certain limited
circumstances and the information on a
piece of paper in a filing cabinet
somewhere is not going to be shared so
that somebody who's concerned about
their personal information identified
being shared
is going to have a lot less likelihood
of having that happen yes thank you very
much for that clarification
representative cushman
thank you mr chairman and it's just a
further clarification from my friend
representative gay
the only people who
whose records the department would be
holding on to in the event that they
asked for it to be withdrawn
it would and it would be somewhere
separate from the registry would be
those who received
immunization from
the state
that is correct
um yeah just for further clarification
it was under emergency order 76 and it
was the covid19 vaccine only
any further questions on the amendment
can i call the question
well technically you can i believe your
statement should read may you call a
question yes you may
we haven't actually done that yet
so we need to make a motion for you to
call it no no no committee procedure is
informal and we do not have calling the
question in committee no speak to your
caucus
[Laughter]
crying
no comment would somebody please um make
a sensible
wonderful motion here i'll make the
motion
all right merchant and lay on on
2022-09
and if we were less formal
your suggestion would be taken but we're
going to do it anyway
so will the clerk please call the roll
representative leon
yes representative mcmahon
representative acton yes representative
gay
representative cushman yes
representative folsom yes representative
kelsey yes representative king
yes representative co-fault
yes representative delemus
representative weber
representative freitas
yes
representative snow yes representative
knurk yes
sorry representative query
yes representative cannon
yes
representative nutter uppam yes
representative shapiro yes
representative woods yes representative
merchant
yes representative pearson yes
21-0
now the chair will entertain a second
motion
and remember
you get to write the blurb
i shouldn't have said that now that
nobody will do it
we could just sign some could we assign
somebody else we can
representative cushman
would you wave who somebody in
some someone just spoke she's just
waving over there
oh hi
oh what oh you want to do it
thanks you do have a good literary style
yes she does um
okay
um
representative cushman did but i would
like to have a democrat
second second lucy or who
does one of you yield to the other or
merchant
all right so we have before some uh
the motion ought to pass as amended on
house bill 14 87 as amended by 2022-0983
moved by representative cushman seconded
by representative merchant and would the
clerk please call the roll
representative leon yes representative
mcmahon representative acton yes
representative gay
representative cushman yes
representative folsom yes representative
kelsey yes representative king yes
representative kobalt yes representative
delemus representative weber
representative freitas
yes
representative snow
yes representative knurk yes
representative query
yes representative cannon yes
representative nutter uppam yes
representative shapiro
yes representative woods yes
representative
merchant yes
representative pearson yes
21-0
you know what that means
it could go on consent unless there's
objection
no and i see none
so representative cushman among your
other duties
thank you
and
all right and for the record i should
have done this before
there were
262 sign ups in favor of this
bill original bill and 49 against
this ends the
exec session on house bill 1487.
she's trying to
do you have a bill do you need a bill
writer or something to talk to her
we're not going
good
open the hearing on house bill 1345
relative to the release of
a teenager's medical records to a parent
or guardian prime sponsor representative
gay
and there is an amendment to this that i
have
there's amendment 13
sorry amendment 6 6 8
and some are going this way and
i'm going that way and another one's
going this way
it's coming it's coming in three four
amendments are coming six six eight
you may already have copies because i
passed about like two weeks ago
well
and for the record 26 people signed in
in favor of this bill
and three against
lucy thank
you excuse me
ladies
um
uh
uh before we
continue i'm going to ask everyone for a
moment of silence to honor the memory of
the late ronnie cushing
thank you everyone
representative gay would you wish to
speak to your amendment please
yes ma'am
could i just ask to see the democrats
across the hall when we're done
thank you
would you introduce your amendment
please
i move that we adopt amendments
for house bill 1345. and do we have a
second
all right representative kelsey now
representative gay please speak to your
amendment
668.
uh the amendment was necessary because
we needed to clarify
that
we still had to accommodate
federal requirements
that restrict
there are a few restrictions right now
for
on release of a minor a 13 year old and
above
uh
to release their records to their
parents which
accidentally i think
got passed when they were trying to
protect certain records
of
of a teenager
they kind of overstepped and just said
a parent had no access to their
teenager's records unless the child
wrote them
a release which is extremely burdensome
to
parents and i would expect two providers
to keep those records
but you have to
you have to accommodate the fact that
there are federal requirements
and there is a specific
uh
new hampshire law
prohibiting
uh just releasing
a certain
type of
treatment
so that has to be
that i had to put that back in the
in the uh
bill
so that's why the what was added was
line eight in the amendment
as directed by federal or specific state
law
any comments or questions representative
merchant
i want to say thank you to
representative gay for making the
clarification because i think this does
clarify a lot of things
and what it really comes down to is that
if there is a
federal or specific state law we have to
honor that
for multiple reasons so therefore by
adding those words into your amendment i
think it clarifies it immensely
thank you
oh shall i make the motion now the
motion hit you made the motion already
all second you may know it's already
been seconded um
so uh i know we're eager the amendment
zero six six eight
to house bill
1345 the motion was ought to pass it was
moved by representative gay it was
seconded by representative kelsey
and when the clerk is ready please call
the roll representative leon yes
representative mcmahon representative
acton yes representative gay yes
representative cushman yes
representative folsom yes representative
kelsey yes representative king yes
representative cofoult yes
representative delemus
representative weber
representative freitas
representative snow yes representative
knurk yes representative querrey
yes representative cannon yes
representative neder uppam yes
representative shapiro yes
representative woods yes representative
merchant yes representative pearson yes
21-0 rep the chair calls on
representative gay for a follow-up
motion
as amended by
that has been moved by representative
gay is representative weber
any further discussion
the motion before us
is house bill 1345
is amended by
amendment 2022-0668
h
the motion is ought to pass as amendment
as amended it was moved by
representative gay and seconded by
representative weber would the clerk
please call the roll representative leon
yes representative mcmahon
representative acton yes representative
gay
representative cushman yes
representative folsom yes representative
kelsey
yes representative king yes
representative cofoult yes
representative delemus
representative weber
representative freitas yes
representative snow yes representative
knurk yes representative querrey
yes
representative cannon yes representative
nutter upham yes representative shapiro
yes representative woods yes
representative merchant yes
representative pearson yes
carries 21-0
i don't sense anybody
is objecting to this to go on to consent
and this means representative gay
you get to write the committee report
back
they raise them tough down in houston
don't they
representative canuck
just a thing regarding renny cushing
uh we did get an email and they asked
that we would not discuss his death
online until an official statement has
been released and that would not be
until at least this evening so we can
talk about it here but nothing online
please
i have no idea what many people prefer
not to do
i would suggest that we wait and find
out what the family's wishes are because
they might have an alternative
suggestion
uh but i think it's a very kind and
welcome
gesture of some sort thank you
this actually now it closes the
executive session officially on house
bill
1345.
um
i would like to open reopen the um
discussion on uh 1044
that we had looked at before
the ruling of the speaker is the
amendment to this is non-germane
it has been requested that there be a
hearing on this the calendar doesn't
allow it i will not do that
the question is for later and my
suggestion to the um
prime
sponsor of well actually the prime
sponsor no the sponsor of the amendment
is that you work with the senate
committee on whatever bill is closest to
this
and then um you will come up with if you
choose an amendment that is close enough
that it doesn't have to be ruled
non-germane that makes life easier so i
would say talk to the senate
counterparts find out what they've got
and when we take bills on crossover
that's when we'll do this
well
i do have an amendment here for us to
send over to the senate
in the hopes that
if we find we do need to make those
non-german changes
we can take that up in a senate
committee later
all right i've just received this
amendment representative
weber
i think that's answered my question i
was going to ask what you were proposing
to do with the bill in the interim but
if we're going to look at a different
amendment we can proceed to a different
amendment we can and and take a look at
it and
those of you who are really wise at this
um
sort of things see how close it looks
because if it is not close we have to
have another ruling on the germaness of
the amendment
my guess is that representative cushman
being a good writer has probably
presented us with something that is
germane
thank you mr chairman i i did speak to
speaker packard and the issue were the
uh two additional sections of that bill
um that had to do with the patient bill
of rights i mean with that amendment
that had to do with the patient bill of
rights so this
is just
um
an amendment to the first part of the
bill looks very much more like the
original bill it just adds the words uh
operates on a membership-based business
model
representative weber
i appreciate the clarification i
certainly appreciate the removal of the
non-germane portion and and this
certainly
is simply a modification of the original
bill
i'm still against it for all the reasons
we said earlier and i'm not going to
bother to repeat them because
you've heard them all before thank you
and i completely agree and
for the sake of brevity i would move
that we adopt amendment
2022-1
house bill 1044
uh one second please hold that thought
um
choking in the paperwork here
momentarily
okay amendment
nine nine one
moved by cushman
and representative cofold seconds this
amendment now further discussion
representative kanark
i will oppose the amendment for the same
reason that i continue to oppose the
bill
and that is that this is highly likely
to bankrupt our critical access
hospitals
who
if they lose a even just a small portion
of their
private payer
or insured
boxes not insured
private payer i know there's those who
can pay
if they leave
they will not be able to stay afloat and
they're going to have to cut services
and for those of us in rural areas
the emergency services
maternity services
are critical to our area
because you don't have a lot of time
necessarily to go driving off to a
hospital 100 miles away to have your
baby or to get taken care of when you
get run over by a car
it does create also a two-tiered health
care system those who can pay and then
the rest of the people
it's not even that they're going to get
secondary care but they're likely to
receive potentially
no care
because if you cannot
stay afloat
as a critical access hospital by losing
your revenue
the services will be gone
and again we have seen that particularly
with the closure of some maternity
services
in the state
when they've just not been able to
keep in the in the bla in the black
they're in the red chronically and they
have to cut services that lose money and
this is a real problem
to our providing health care
particularly in our rural areas
so i think it has
i'm not sure if i want to call them
unintended maybe they're intended but
they have clear unintended consequences
of denying health care to a large swath
of people
chair has two thoughts um
one as you know
my wife and i run a
family practice medicine slash
counseling
massage
facility in kingston
and we are very much an alternative
to
what we all agree is
kind of a messed up
system
so my thought is
there can be a variety of ways
to put different models in place
this isn't the only option we have it
isn't
what's in this bill
versus
everything else there are other models
there can be many more
my second thought is i lived in england
for three years
and there were private pay hospitals
and the local hospitals were not
impoverished by there being private pay
because you had complete government
funded socialized medicine so if you
want to put the price if you want to put
up private pay hospitals and skim up the
cream be prepared that the next step
will be complete european style
socialized medicine and if you don't
want that then perhaps you don't want to
bankrupt the local
hospitals that exist so there's my
thoughts
representative gay
if i'm if i'm not wrong it seems like a
real serious problem is that our
medicare
doesn't pay
sufficiently
for the services
and that seems to be it's being propped
up by people paying
who who are in short
so it seems like that's an issue we
really need to
to work on
i don't i don't know any of it i i could
ask you a million questions right now
about what's the percentage that we get
reimbursed by the federal government are
we restricted by the federal government
on what we can charge
things like that it just seems like that
is such a serious issue
that it's at the basis of all our costs
representative
leon
thank you mr chairman um i i do
appreciate that some areas don't have a
very robust healthcare market even when
there is just the hospital in the
critical access hospital
when you're looking at people who are
putting this would be creating these
facilities
on the direct pay or membership-based
model they're going to need a larger
field to draw from than the north
country or these other areas that are
served by the critical access hospitals
i i really
only see the possibility of this being
viable in the highly populated areas in
the southern part of the state at this
point
and by doing that and having a
option
i
i don't see them getting very large i
don't see
[Music]
a giant competition for our established
system because a lot of people do enjoy
having their insurance coverage
but having an option to do this and
instead of your insurance company being
the ultimate client of the health care
system when you're paying you're the one
who's paying and it changes the dynamic
so i'd like to see us have a chance to
offer these facilities here in new
hampshire i think it'd be niche i think
it'd be small that's what keeps the new
zealand system afloat
i've spoken with surgeons there they
have socialized medicine
they didn't have those they wouldn't
have a chance so i i want to see this
have a chance to take root here in new
hampshire
representative kanark
but you just made the important point
they have socialized medicine we do not
when we do not this will be a problem
and so representative pearson made the
commentary person made the comment if we
did have a system like england and
norway also has the same thing
then it works fine to have these private
things because there everybody has
coverage and the coverage actually pays
because they invest in it the problem
with us is we do not put enough money
into medicare or medicaid that is the
problem but to quote president trump who
knew health care was complex it is
complex and it's not a problem we're
going to fix here today but the bottom
line is
the comment you made at the end there
was exactly right they have socialized
medicine we do not
representative leon um thank you mr
chairman we also have a system that
subsidizes health care throughout the
whole world through the privately
insured americans and uh we have lots of
lots of big issues i see this as a small
and niche if it does take root but we
probably should
stop talking start voting
thank you
seeing nothing further the matter before
us is the amendment zero nine nine one
as moved by representative cushman
and seconded by representative co-fault
would the clerk please call the roll
representative leon yes representative
mcmahon yes representative acton yes
representative gay
representative cushman yes
representative folsom yes representative
kelsey yes representative king yes
representative co-fault yes
representative delemus
representative weber
i yeah i gotcha
representative freitas
representative snow
representative knurk no representative
query no representative cannon no
representative nutter upham no
representative shapiro
no representative woods no
representative merchant no
representative pearson
no
11 10. the motion fails
representative knurk
i move itl
the motion on the bill is itl
representative
canaric do i have a second
representative weber any further
discussion
seeing none the motion before us is
an expedient to legislate on house bill
moved by representative knurk and
seconded by representative weber
and would the clerk please call the roll
representative leon now representative
mcmahon
representative acton yes
representative gay
representative cushman now
representative folsom no representative
kelsey now
representative king
yes representative cofoult
no
representative delemus
representative webber
representative freitas yes
representative snow yes representative
knurk yes representative query
yes representative cannon yes
representative nutter upham yes
representative shapiro
representative woods yes representative
merchant yes representative pearson yes
7. the motion
in expedient to legislate carries
fourteen to seven who will write the
committee report representative connerk
will write the committee report who
would like to write the minority report
representative cushman thank you so much
this
concludes the hearing on house bill
1044 and for the last item to be taken
up today
the relative bill i opened the exact
session on house bill
1347 which is very similar in many ways
and there is an amendment that
representative cushman is
handing out
and this is the last one that's the last
most of the rest of them
representative cushman the amendment you
just handed out
996 does this replace 937 that you had
previously done
yes it does okay thank you
and we'll give people a few minutes to
read the amendment that has just been
created
i don't know raise the question
representative cushman would you
introduce your amendment to us please
yes thank you before you have um
government
0996h
um so that the last bill we heard was
the whole enchilada this is just a small
bite i limited
my original bill to only apply to
nursing homes and rehabs
so
and as i discussed in the hearing for
for this bill
we did need to remove the moratorium on
new facilities that was discussed during
the hearing
so
what you have is the removal of that
moratorium for new
nursing homes and rehabs if they operate
on a membership based business model or
exclusively provide services to persons
who make direct payment
and in section two
it exempts these facilities
in paragraph two of that section
only nursing homes again intermediate
care and rehabs
that operate on this so it exempts them
from 1a and 1b
so they shall
not be required to accept all forms of
payment
and they shall not be required to have
the
assistance plan for people who are
uninsured
now i don't think we're going to have
the same argument about critical care
hospitals closing when this is only
nursing homes and rehab so i hope that
that barrier being removed that we can
come to an agreement you know that this
is a good option for people if they want
to pay have a different way to pay
for nursing care that private facilities
should be able to operate in new
hampshire
representative canark
in our county nursing homes and in many
other nursing homes the primary provider
of payment is medicaid
that is that is how they get the
reimbursement
we are just going through our budgetary
process in carroll county right now
and we
the majority of our income comes from
medicaid we have a small amount from
private pay but that small number of
private pay people is very important for
us
i would still make precisely the same
argument and that is that if you skim
off
those private pay people into another
facility
our county nursing homes
will not be able to function or well
they'll be able to function as long as
we increase our property tax rate
immensely
and that's precisely the outcome because
let us say that you get 60 of your out
income from medicaid and you get 40 from
private pay and let's say you only you
lose a small amount but you lose let's
say 10 percent and
for i don't remember the exact number on
our earth but i think ours is about 17
million dollars and
because we're a small one
and so i could do the math but i'm not
going to worry about the calculation but
it's a few million dollars it is going
to increase the property tax rate
immensely so if you are prepared to
increase the property tax rate in your
county
this is a wonderful bill if not
uh if you're not prepared for that we
should not pass this bill and that's
only the county nursing homes any other
nursing homes who are trying to survive
well also then go bankrupt so the
various private nursing homes would not
be able to afford to stay in business
representative
snow
i'm looking at uh line 10
of the amendment
and and that says no new license shall
be issued for and there should be no
increase in license capacity of any
nursing home blah blah blah or any other
services unless that person is one of
these
uh
membership only or pay
does this go back does this bring the
certificate of need
process back so you can't expand or
develop a new nursing home unless you go
before some government board to be
approved that's what it sounds like that
is the remainder of the certificate of
need law that you read the only part
that i'm adding is what's in bold what
you what you first read on line 10 is
what is currently in law and that was
the leftover
pieces after the certificate of need
board was removed
they
one of the conditions of that
negotiation was to leave in law that
there's a moratorium on
new or expanding
medical facilities nursing homes and
rehabs
and why wouldn't we
if we're going to remove
that
restriction on
existing nursing homes and rehab
facilities and only grant it
to the membership only and private pay
why wouldn't we remove it for everybody
why why do we only give these people an
advantage over all the existing nursing
homes
currently in existence
well unfortunately
there was a lot of pushback on efforts
to remove the moratorium for anybody
and
we're trying to set up an alternative
option for people but but you're giving
them a distinct advantage by saying
they're not subject to the remaining
certificate of need process
so they can blow it up as much as they
want and everybody else can't
i find it very
ironic that
you're talking about having this
advantage when
this entire conversation on this bill in
the last was resistance to removing
protectionism from our highly advantaged
facilities that currently exist
this is to open up the market and
provide options currently those
facilities that exist now are protected
by
laws that ensure there is no competition
against them
so this is not it's removing a
disadvantage
in terms of these private facilities
that are private pay
doesn't seem fair to me
thank you representative representative
canarch
representative merchant
my understanding is this already exists
so i don't know why we need the law um
i'll give an example and i'll need to
confirm this because i have a chance to
do this i could do this probably
overnight to be sure about this my facts
but there are places like kendall
hanover which is a private community
and therefore you cannot get into
kendall unless you have the wealth and
the means to do it
and they also have nursing homes built
into it i don't believe that nursing
home the operate
has to come under the moratorium of the
state because it's privately funded
so i commend you for what you're doing
representative cushman but i believe
that already exists in the market today
there are places that people who have
the wealth can go
without having to worry about
the market because the market's already
taking care of it that's in my opinion
again i can call somebody this evening
who i know there to confirm that in fact
papers places like kendall which are
called residential
can you continuum care community
are in fact private
and they don't take medicare
so a residential continuing care
community is typically like an assisted
living you know it goes from
you have on the facility okay you go
from independent living
to assisted living
to a nursing home all in one community
but you have to buy into it you have to
pay for it
there's no subsidization coming from
outside sources
they will occasionally bill from
medicare if they're able to but it's not
required you don't have to have it
so i just don't understand how
that's legal plus we heard from the
department before
when we were having the conversation on
this bill that
it was confirmed you can't operate you
can't have a nursing home or a rehab
that doesn't take medic all payers
because they fall under this statute 151
colon 2 that
you know
governs the licensure for these
facilities so they can't obtain a
license unless they accept all payers
they fall under that
representative webber
i'm i'm loath to put mr williams on the
spot but i was about to
take i'm going to say that kendall at
hanover exists river mead and
peterborough exists i'm hearing behind
me that a new community just opened in
keene so
there are two in nashua
they are private pay communities that
are a continuum of care
all over the state and so i'm hoping
against hope that they're not all
illegal and all of their residents
aren't about to be turfed out and i'm
hoping that mr williams can explain that
to us
thank you so much
yes the the issue of the
continuing care um community residential
uh centers otherwise known as the ccrcs
ccrcs have been existence and you've got
a very good description of how they
operate because they are continuing to
care everything from you know from a
basic living to moving to assisted
living into acute nursing facility care
there was legislation brought up within
about the last eight years or so
dealing with the overlapping authority
between the department of health and
human services and that of the insurance
department because we do
license the facilities portion of it but
in terms of how that they they operate
they fall under the insurance statute so
if you want legislation for next year to
look at this is a issue that has been
looked at in the past but never resulted
in clarifying legislation
between the duties of the department of
health and services and that of the crc
crcs to my knowledge
ccc or whatever it is
are
are perfectly fine but there is that
anomaly of needing to look at that issue
if you research bills that were filed by
then senator andy sanborn i know this
was a very important issue to him
because he charged me on a late day i'm
sure like this to looking into this and
to get a meeting together with
representatives from the insurance
department to try to see what we can do
to vet that
far scope from i'm sure the questions
here today but i hope that was a
responsive to your questions
at 4 35 in the afternoon
don't tell them that mr williams um
the the bill is about a
private pay nursing home the answers i'm
hearing are about continuum of care
the question remains is there any legal
private only
nursing home not continuum of care in
the state of new hampshire
okay um i can confirm that i believe
working with attorney john martin who
used to oversee those facilities but has
not done so for a few years when i
talked with them again this is point in
time information uh around three or four
years ago that there i believe there was
one private facility out towards i want
to say the stratfor county area of the
state um if it
if i'm pretty sure meeting your
definition but otherwise i'd have to
really go back and to identify where we
are a point in time now that is dated
information
okay representative thank you
representative shapiro
yes thank you mr chairman um i want to
go back to um
when representative gay was talking
about
medicare and medicaid not paying
adequately which is maybe the
foundational
cause for some of these problems and i
i wholeheartedly agree and we in new
hampshire don't have any
ability to affect medicare rates but we
absolutely have the ability to affect
medicaid rates
so i hope that um
we can collaborate on a bill to raise
medicaid rates next year
um one of my concerns with this um
with this bill is that it
um
it creates a two it's potentially
creates a two-tier
system of care and i think we already
have a two-tier system of care
hillside village is a continuing care
facility that opened in keene a few
years ago and
you have to be
wealthy or upper middle class to be able
to afford to go there
the county nursing home which in
cheshire county is excellent
is where all the people who end up who
don't have money or who run out of money
and have to rely on medicaid so we
already have
to some degree a two-tier system of care
but i think this would just increase
that and
i'm not in favor of increasing that so i
would vote against this bill
representative weber
and just to carry that reasoning along a
little bit further
no this is not going to affect the
critical care access hospitals but it
certainly affects the county nursing
homes and if you go to your county
delegation meeting every year
the population of the county nursing
home is sicker
heavier they need more bariatric beds
they need more
services
because the county nursing home is the
nursing home of last resort so if you
don't have the resources to go anywhere
else
and if you're a management issue so
nobody else wants to take you
you go to the county nursing home
and different counties have different
experience i keep hearing that
hillsborough county nursing home
actually makes a profit which is
astounding to those of us from
from cheshire county but we have an
excellent nursing home
which is the nursing home of last resort
but that's done on the back of the
taxpayers so if you once again if you
skim off the paying patients
your property tax rates are going to go
up
as um the member one of the members of
the county delegation for rockingham
county that's charged with knowing the
nursing home situation i would second
what representative webber just said
representative woods
yeah thank you i'm chair of the
merrimack county nursing home budget
committee
uh one don't go far mr williams
one of the other things that's not been
mentioned is is the domino effect is the
fact that one of the serious problems of
being able to keep a census up so you
can have income
is personnel
and with
competing with the paid
those nurses will go there
therefore
they won't be able to go to the county
nursing home and that further
exacerbates the problem when you have
the domino effect if you don't have the
personality you can't keep the census
and there we therefore we go farther
down so there is that dimension that uh
comes into play
representative
canuck
i've already explained why i oppose the
bill and the amendment in general but i
would also like to bring up that i think
this amendment
also
has a feature in it which is rather
non-germane because
what the first section is doing
is changing
the issues about the certificate of need
it's modifying that we did not have a
hearing on that issue that was not part
of the original bill
and as a result i think we would be
doing a disservice to the public and to
the various nursing homes and everybody
else
to consider this amendment and
pass it or even not pass it without
having a proper public hearing and i
don't think we should have a public
hearing i think that's amendment should
be turned back
representative cushman thank you mr
chairman i had mentioned this piece as
being integral to that bill in my
introduction of the bill during the
hearing
and um everyone who was there had an
opportunity to comment on that that i
made it very clear that i wanted the
moratorium lifted or i felt that the
bill
probably wouldn't work
um
but on the topic of like we're all
admitting here that there's a problem i
think that it originated with medicare
and medicaid in the beginning and
insurance i mean these things take away
from
the care being the product and instead
you're purchasing discounts on the cost
of care so it's not transparent um
we're not paying for
what we're getting we're paying for an
intermediary a third party
and i definitely don't agree that a one
payer system is the way to deal with
that i think we need market competition
and we need plenty of options and you
know to meet the demand and i think that
if these alternative options become
available adoption will be slow
and if it proves that people who that it
offers
better services at a lower cost and
makes it affordable for people then
there's no harm in eventually
those outdated systems
um
you know
fading out and these new systems
taking over and you know offering people
a better
product
representative cushman um i thought i
heard you say please clarify in case i
got it wrong this new amendment we're
looking at did you run this by the
speaker
i did not run it specifically by him but
i told him we talked about what was in
the other bill and the patient bill of
rights was the
all of that language was the main issue
okay so you did talk about the
amendments that were ruled non-germaine
yes along the way to coming up with
something that would pass muster yeah
hearing you say yes thank you
representative weber
i'm just going to suggest to everybody
that we are not going to solve the
problems of the health care industry in
the state in in the state of new
hampshire or the
united states and we only have one small
piece in front of us and perhaps it
might be time to vote on that
i was hoping to solve the health care
crisis
another day
tomorrow
representative cushman would you care to
make a motion
i'm going to motion that we adopt the
amendment
2022-0996-h2 house bill 1347. is there a
second on this amendment representative
cofoult thank you very much
any further discussion before we vote
representative gay
under
under this amendment
if a person has the money to go into a
private pay
and runs out of money
what happens to that person
my mother was in a private pay that
accepted medicaid so when she ran out of
money she switched over to medicaid
but it was private it was the jewish
nursing home in houston which is very
high quality
but i'm trying to understand how that
compares to this
representative weber
so in the county nursing home you pay
until you
qualify for medicaid and then medicaid
takes over
in
med
and many other nursing homes have that
policy as well
but i have been told by our
administrator that
there are nursing homes that when you
run out of money
they go then they come to the county
nursing home because there isn't
anywhere else for them to go
so
if
because this is a private pay
model
and a membership model
unless there is some kind of
pre-arranged agreement that somebody's
going to keep people forever
when they run out of money they're going
to come to the county nursing home
on medicaid
representative canuck
in other words
they'll be kicked out of the nursing
home that they're in
is that true yeah that's true
well i suppose it depends on the policy
there's nothing in here that says they
can't have a
charity care or that the membership
wouldn't be a lifelong thing that you
pay into so you pay for your entire care
ahead of time i think that the business
model is up to the entrepreneurs who
want to start the business and there are
options
to deal with that and people are
creative when they're starting
businesses and people who start these
businesses want to help people generally
but
one option
is when
the patient runs out of money
you gotta go
there's only so many charity cases an
organization can have i think of my mom
who was in one in massachusetts
and there was only so many that they
could carry
there were models where you sign over
all of your property to the nursing home
and they might say okay we now own a
three hundred thousand dollar house and
we'll make a deal how many years that'll
get you
but still
they have to run a business
even if they allow themselves a low
profit margin they have to run
themselves a business and when people
stop paying
um they can only take so many of those
representative merchants
i think basically you hit the nail on
the head
when you deal with the continuing care
retirement community
in order to be part of it
to ensure from a business model
the organization is not
go bankrupt
you have to front load it
i know some of them are charging
anywhere from 750 000 to a million
dollars
entrance fees
to guarantee that there's enough money
for them to take care of you for the
rest of your life
on top of that you have to also pay
monthly fees
so i'm going to go back and said before
this business model exists today
there's no need for this bill because it
does already exist in the state of new
hampshire those who have the means and
have the funds
can acquire that level of care
and to be taken care of from the day
they move in to the day they move out
so therefore i don't think the bill
really needs to be addressed or passed
because we already have the free market
working the way it should
seeing no further
discussion the question before us is
amendment
h
to house bill 1347
moved by representative cushman and
seconded by representative cofault would
the clerk please call the role
representative leon yes
representative mcmahon
representative acton yes representative
gay
representative cushman yes
representative folsom yes representative
kelsey yes representative king
yes representative cofoult yes
representative delemus representative
weber representative freitas
representative snow
representative knurk no representative
query
no
representative cannon no representative
nutter upham no representative shapiro
no representative woods no
representative merchant no
representative pearson yes
carries 11 to 10.
the chair will now entertain a second
emotion second motion
thank you mr chairman
my second motion is that we uh vote
ought to pass
on house bill 1347 as amended by
amendment 2022-096-h
and do i hear a second
representative cofoult
discussion
for me the tiebreaker was if this
already exists
putting it into law again
won't do any difference so what the heck
if it's already there okay well that's
my thought representative canarch
yes but that has to do with these
facilities that are the
nursing facilities and such that are
continuing care
we still have
our county nursing homes and other
nursing homes that are not
in that
uh the rest of the
amendment and actually the original bill
does refer to all of that
and so we still are going to have the
problem that
if we're going to do this we should have
an amendment to uh help out the counties
with backfilling the the
downshifting we're going to do to them
for property tax
because it will still be a problem so
yes i agree there are these continuing
care communities
that uh can pull that off
for in a continuum of care but most
people are not doing that most people
are going to the county nursing home
where again as representative weber said
they're going to be private paid till
they spend on their assets then they
become medicare
and we then have to pay for them with
medicare sorry medicaid medicaid
medicaid funds
um
and if they're in one of these other
private places they could just get the
boot unless they're in a continuing care
thing and have uh given that front-end
loading
so
we still are going to see our property
taxes rise perhaps substantially
to be able to maintain our county
nursing homes
we just opened a big facility in
kingston that is private pay
and
oh my gosh
is it
upscale
and since one of my jobs in the county
delegation is to look after the nursing
homes that was my immediate thought
as of yet and this other facility has
now been open for three years we have
not seen a financial impact on our
county nursing home i'm not saying that
won't happen in a year or two or three
or four but it has not happened yet
seeing no further discussion the matter
before us is house bill
as amended by
amendment 2022-096-h
[Music]
moved by representative cushman
seconded by representative cofoult would
the clerk please call the role
representative leon yes representative
mcmahon
representative acton yes representative
gay
representative cushman yes
representative folsom yes representative
kelsey yes representative king
yes representative kobalt yes
representative delemus representative
weber
representative freitas
representative snow representative knurk
no representative query no
representative cannon no representative
nutter upham no representative shapiro
no representative woods no
representative merchant yes
representative pearson yes
one two three four five six seven eight
nine twelve to nine
and the bill as amended carries 12 to 9.
just a few things as we
wrap it up here
as many blurbs as you can send me i am
going from here to my office where i
will stay
for i don't know how long um i do have a
tv there and the ncis has a new episode
at nine o'clock uh may i i i'd be glad
to do the minority report on that and
for the clerk
yes i think that's important for the
clerk the minority report and minority
motion would be itl okay thank you
so
the blurb uh will be cushman
cushman for the committee
and canark for the minority
um and this closes the hearing on 1347
sorry for jumping the gun just a
reminder we are meeting tomorrow but not
here we have been relegated to rooms
201-3
just also a reminder if you haven't
jotted it down we have the leon
shapiro vacation week of march 21 to 5
and representative weber has asked for
a meeting of the democrats afterwards
representative shapiro when is the
outside um
date for having the reports i have to
have them in noonish on wednesday
so i have to have them from you
before-ish
okay this closes the meeting drive
carefully
you